Bum,
bum,
bum bum.
Three,
two,
boom.
Can you lower it?
Ladies and gentleman,
Mauro run Allo big John McCarthy.
Uh,
Eddie Bravo rocking the old
school Elio Gracie shirt.
I love that shirt and respect.
Deep respect Brendan motherfucking shop.
Oh,
and I got to sugar Sean O'Malley shirt.
I might strip down later
and put his mother fucker.
I was that the best shirt Reebok's ever.
Maybe it might be one of the dopest.
Sure.
It's pretty great.
Reebok.
Reebok is getting better,
man.
I'll give it to him.
I'm wearing a pair of Reeboks right home.
I thought it was not,
I thought I was [inaudible] earlier today.
Reebok send me a bunch of sneakers,
but that's a dope shirt right there.
You know what I mean?
I was super critical on them for a while.
They're getting way better,
man.
Way Better.
This is good that they,
when they posted that,
I got my boy who works at Reebok,
I send a screenshot.
I went,
God damn,
you guys hit this one out of the park.
They're embracing it.
They're embracing the
fact that he's a stoner,
like heavy duty.
Yeah,
it's just a fun shirt.
Talks about what go.
Does Instagram dude's
getting high all day?
Did you see him on the last fight?
Well,
he just takes time off.
I mean you don't have to
take much time off anymore.
No.
Two weeks.
Two days.
Days.
Yeah.
New Usada rules.
You just can't be high when you fight
depending where you fight though.
Right.
Cause there there's some issues coming up.
I forget which state they do it different.
Probably Texas commissions are haters.
So Dylan,
Dennis,
this is not as MMA debut.
Oh against Kyle Walker and Eddie.
Tell us about Dylan's Jujitsu.
He's pretty high level.
Yeah,
he's one of the best around for sure.
He had an amazing match with
Gordon Ryan at 2017 Abu Dhabi.
I mean the fight was really close.
It could've went either way and they
gave it the judge's decision gave it to
Gordon and Gordon when I
went on to win his division.
So He's,
he's top of the food chain and you know,
he was with Marcello Garcia.
He got his black belt
from Marcella Garcia.
Yeah.
Marcello kicked him out for shit talking.
Right.
It's not the deal for,
you know,
he,
he started hanging out with Conor McGregor
and Marcella Garcia is the opposite
of that kind of shit.
Her humble.
Incredibly humble.
Yeah.
You would think though that Marcello
and him would work it out though.
And I have a guy and the
guy's a high level black belt,
like obviously it's just too much drama.
But Dylan in real life,
he's a super great guy.
He's just trying to make some money.
He,
uh,
he's smart talking.
He got shit to Jon Jones and I,
and here we go.
Oh,
that's stupid.
I know all these guys talking shit that
John John's are eventually going to have
to meet him and they will get slapped.
When I saw Dylan,
when the Conor and Floyd fight,
me and him sat next to each other,
he was the nicest guy in the world,
man.
Look at him.
His fans,
he's very Conor McGregor.
Ask With that same coaching.
So coaching,
same camp.
Oh Dude.
He's got real problems with just striking.
That dude just stepped in and
cleaned him with that left.
Oh Shit.
He got some problems.
His standup is super rudimentary.
Takedowns are they better be good.
Well it's Kinda,
he's Kinda like the Mackenzie dern,
right of,
well,
he's obviously closing the distance too,
which is a problem because
it's obvious you're calming in.
The guy could just wait on you.
His distance control several times.
He's been clipped by that left hand.
Oh Dude.
If this guy can keep this fight stand.
Okay.
Yeah.
His kicks are stiff.
Yeah,
it's,
but his Jujitsu is this shit.
If he gets his fight to these kind of
like an alley cat version of Connor,
like super alley cat.
I don't real rough.
He pulls back with his chin straight
up in the air to get a clinch.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
Yeah.
Let's jump to God.
I like,
it doesn't happen enough fatty now.
It doesn't happen if
you get the skills down,
if he can't take the guy down and you
have your dangerous off your back.
Pulling Guard is great.
Right?
He's hooking it and he's about to
get them in an arm bar right here.
This is good.
This guy's in trouble.
If this guy is gonna sweep,
this guy knows the game.
I was gonna pull out of this shit.
Oh No,
he's gonna.
He's gonna heal her.
Come watch him.
He's got him.
It's in deep.
It's over.
Yes.
That was fun for sure.
There he goes.
And that's a wrap.
I think he's okay.
He pulled guard and she got to heal hook.
Pretty sweet.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
It was a suite here.
Opponent.
I don't have a problem
giving them a warm up fight,
like the source first one first.
MMA fight your belt door.
He's still getting worse.
Could be in Pico,
your first fight.
You know what I'm saying?
Just so things,
man,
when I see a dude get his
knee ripped apart like that,
like that dude's fucked.
Look at him.
He's in pain.
You could get your shoulder ripped
apart and come on the exact same way.
So I know,
but it's,
it's weird,
right?
I mean,
I'm not saying it makes sense to tap.
That's it.
Yeah.
I think the problem is guys aren't too
familiar with what goes on with the leg
legs.
So by the time they're
tapping it's too late.
Yeah.
But what I'm saying is
for whatever reason,
for me,
when I watch it,
I cringe McCurry with Lego.
I agree.
Like if I see a guy get his arm broken,
it doesn't bother me.
Like I see a guy get his knee ripped
apart cause we're not used to seeing it.
I don't know,
man.
I maybe it's because I
know that tap you like,
you only have so much time to tap.
Like your shit's gonna explode.
Maybe it's just,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
But when a guy is really good at it,
you know,
if you fuck up an ankle,
he's out for a grip.
Yeah.
Yup,
Yup.
Oh Dad.
I said no asked.
He won't tell.
Oh,
nasty toehold.
I had a bad angle as a tone.
That was a heel hook initially.
Yeah.
I thought so too.
But they didn't really show it.
They couldn't see his
back was to write it.
He can't see it.
Well,
you know what,
man?
I mean,
I liked the fact that he's in there,
but man,
I feel like w just watching
him move with his standup,
I'd like to see him.
That's his first fight.
Brother.
I know,
but I'd like to see him to get
some more standup training.
Just it seems like,
I mean,
look,
if he gets guys to the ground,
they're there in a world of shit,
but you could see from his standup,
it's like rudimentary super amateur,
but how's that?
Any different than Michael
Bennett page was zero Jujitsu,
so much as zero Jujitsu.
You know what I'm saying?
That starts on the fee.
Michael [inaudible].
He's a straight up black belt as they get,
when it comes to the ground,
it doesn't matter.
Nickel then and pages tap people.
He's tapped people.
Shit.
I don't,
I don't think his Jujitsu
is as bad as you think so.
Well,
so that light,
not Michael Dubin page.
He's no Dylan Dennis,
but no,
Paul Daley.
That's,
yeah,
that's a good cause.
It's just use off.
Yeah.
If you're high level at one aspect.
Whether it's wrestling,
Jiu Jitsu or striking.
If you're super high level worldclass
you can suck at the other two.
It doesn't matter.
I mean,
look at Green Melvin Manhoef.
He's so dangerous on his feet.
He doesn't really have any Jujitsu,
but it's okay.
It's true.
People still want to see him fight.
We get Damien Meyer,
Jake shields.
My thing is though,
when I see a guy like Dylan
Dannis who so good on the ground,
I really want them to achieve a certain
level of striking proficiency before he
fights.
He fights.
Yeah.
I just feel like we're going
to pay rent the wrestler,
but it's going to put
him in a world of Joe.
He's never been in that
in that cage before.
Right.
So maybe in training he's putting it
all together like you're ready to go.
Man Gets in these.
He's like damn.
Hate his nerves.
Never felt those nerves inside the age.
They took those shots to
took those shots on the chin.
Well,
you got hit with a couple of good
clean left hands and he adjusted.
I'm sure I'm,
I'm a,
I'm about a million percent sure the plan
wasn't to go out there and pull guard.
The fact that he realized,
Oh shit,
this guy's tagging me and he was kind
of hesitant to get in tight to get a
takedown pulling guard
show that he can adapt.
Yeah.
I'm not mad at it at all.
Yeah,
I'm sure that was probably in the plan,
you know,
Plan B,
plan c.
But uh,
if he gets guys the
ground there in the world,
most,
most fighters,
they don't have it in their
plan to pull guard most down.
Not the ones that,
that I've talked to.
It's never part of the plan.
Like this doesn't work
or that doesn't work.
I'm going to pull guard.
Yeah,
that's too bad either.
It's either I'm going to try to
take him down until the bitter end.
Speak a pulling guard,
you know,
Camaros months fighting Damien Maia.
Yes.
Damien Maia to got short notice.
How's that weight cuts on?
That's not good.
Was he supposed to be
fighting ponds and Obo?
Yes.
Uh,
you got hurt and knee injury,
right ma'am?
That car take has taken
a hit because then our,
uh,
our boy,
no time,
um,
isn't fighting shogun so that
to move it because of his,
he,
since he lives here in Germany,
I chose,
well because of his things
going on in Florida with a,
with a felony or whatever these
he's waiting on [inaudible].
So yeah.
So he can travel to Chile
so they have to do it.
Oh,
he beat somebody up.
I'm still on,
but they had to take it off Chile.
Oh,
that cards taking the hit.
Who's,
mine's a monster.
He's a monster.
But you know Damien Maia is a
monster on the ground and oops.
Mons.
Most of his game is the ground.
Yeah.
It's ground and pound.
Most of his game.
It's going to be very interesting to see
or to do other things because of a fun,
it'd be honest,
the big John McCarthy is a big
motherfucker to be interviewing people.
You know what I mean?
Look like I seen him
interviews with flyweights.
Yeah,
he's a big dude.
Like yikes.
Dan is about to drop some
fire on this mic cause he,
he,
you know,
he takes,
he takes after Connor a little too much.
Dropped some purifier.
What is he saying?
We got some volume,
Jamie.
Okay.
It's not working.
Back to the drawing board.
A little work.
Dylan,
come at a seminar one.
Don't forget the seminar.
Walk Home Samurai.
I've heard that before.
Yeah,
never heard that before.
Come find me,
bro.
I'll give you some tips.
We need some work on that shit talking.
You
tighten it up.
Maybe find a diet and
find a doll in the back.
Yeah.
Well,
you know he's all fucking,
that may have been Connor's line.
Maybe he wrote it for him.
Could be
willing to die.
You're willing to die in that.
It might give them a free seminar.
Well,
Dylan dance can be a beast.
A beat though.
Well,
especially if the bell torque
gives them the right matchup.
Why wouldn't you though?
It's his first year.
He's a wrestler too.
He wrestled and wrestled four
or five years growing up.
There's some good fights on this card.
Okay.
Hofeld Lavato versus Gerald Harris.
I liked that fight.
That's a fight.
That's an interesting fight,
man.
Nelson versus Mirko Cro cop.
They'd been given him the test in
some had been giving him the test and
apparently do you,
but do you believe their testing?
When I hear a bell tars testing,
I always like wink wink.
That's like the Olympia Auto Mall.
Oh really?
What do you do?
You give him like a written test?
Did you take today
just to rich dudes are fucking eating
hay and snort and they're on so much echo
poise.
That's like a Canelo.
He came back,
he did the hair falls,
we'll say,
but people are saying bullshit though.
Why?
I guess the the,
the way it was done,
like how do we know what's his hair?
It's coming from his camp exclusive load.
Is it?
Yeah,
it's true.
I was like,
come on man.
Yeah.
It's his kid.
He tested positive for
being a 55 year old trainer.
That's a bummer man.
That that fight is down because now
he's fighting want to Edmonds boys.
He's fighting a triple g's.
[inaudible] took that fucking fun.
Wild Ass.
How Fun would that,
he's got a,
he's got an Indian name.
One of them.
Armenian.
That brother and characters.
Enjoy that man.
Yeah.
Well what are you going to do?
Glendale in the house.
Enjoy that.
Fucking Armenians love to fight,
man.
Yeah,
there's tough.
As they come,
I let them fade or 36 and five Frank Mir.
18 wow.
Yeah.
I'm a favor.
He looked Kinda tick thick.
Yeah.
You don't look good.
They need to let him find Japan again.
Get him on the right
mixture is looking good.
I said frank was like,
you were jacked right now.
I was talking about fit or I said I would.
I was jumped to half guard.
He's like,
what would you do?
I was like,
I went play that striking
down on the first round.
Jumped to half guard if
I had your half guard.
He's like getting good on the
ground and just around town.
There's no death.
I know,
man.
I remember the way Dritan
O'gara oh for sure.
This Day.
Some of the best.
However a different game though.
Yeah,
I'm super suspicious about all
those old fights now though.
You know I'm super suspicious.
Breach brothers super suspicious because
then he comes here and just get fucking
ran soon.
Super sororities
that those weren't fake.
No,
no,
no.
And that's not what I mean.
That's not what I mean.
I mean steroids,
I mean performance enhancing drugs.
I mean we're looking at a different human.
That's what I'm thinking.
Yeah.
It comes in the state,
aren't you guys just saying Bella tour?
Don't really check with joking
around or they do some check in.
They do have state athletic commission,
Russia.
We know that date.
Well then within Japan,
Japan was encouraging 100% you know,
and who knows who was doing
what and who wasn't doing what.
But when you talk to the guys who
were over there like ants and anyway,
and he'll tell you they had it in
capital letters in the contract,
we will not test you for steroids.
And then you look at Vander Lee when he
weighed two 18 when he fought cro cop,
he was heavier than cro
cop when he fought cro cop.
I mean that is just fucking bananas.
But if you look at that,
Joe,
you cannot say that about the
UFC till you saw that came in.
You definitely can.
But you can.
Up until the point I think it's a hair
less because they cannot test days.
The courage to not TRT days.
You're right about TRT
days like Trt v tour,
we always ran yard that was leak.
All those boys.
Yeah.
The guys who were on TRT,
including Frank Frank
was on TRT for awhile.
They were telling fighters
to go up a weight class.
They're like,
you don't want it.
You need to go up.
Well,
they were also telling
fighters that will let you win.
You know,
we know guys.
That was k one same shit.
It's Japan.
He was talking some
dark web shit right now.
Qa now share.
You ruined my childhood.
Cow died tonight.
Listen,
there's,
there was just a lot of shenanigans going
on back in the day and a lot of it was
also,
they were just trying to compete with
the UFC and they were trying to do a big
business and it was awesome.
It was awesome.
I mean,
they were superheroes.
One name for you,
Bob Sapp.
Oh fuck.
Come on son.
Come on.
Sap.
What is 375 pounds with ABS?
I loved that.
He was so jealous.
Three 70 with ABS.
Three 70 and like not bad.
Cardio wasn't bad.
Not Bad.
Oh,
he was on everything though,
bro.
Everything.
They made all the EPRs and
the pis and the EPA is,
and if he was on the
Environmental Protection Agency,
Dea,
the FBI,
the CIA,
he was so big,
he stood out so big in Japan.
He couldn't go anywhere.
Well,
you remember when he was like a
super duper star over in Japan.
But then,
um,
there was a situation with,
I believe it was k one,
they,
they wanted him to sign a
contract after he fought.
And he was like,
I wanted to contract before fucking fight,
man.
Like we got us,
I got to see the contract.
And they like,
you know,
you fight and then contract.
He's like,
fuck you.
This is crazy.
So he walked out of the fight
and he was done after that.
He was the main event.
So he's doing dope.
He's lucky he didn't get Yakuza.
Who's a style?
I think there's 57% child thinks.
How about jail has to
fight the winner of this.
That's crazy dude.
How good it chilled.
Look against rampage.
He looked good.
His wrestling is always good.
He prepares,
he's smart.
I mean say what you want about shale son,
and you know that guy is always prepared.
Neiman Gracie.
Ooh,
this is interesting.
I don't know anything about Javier Torres.
Don't anything about Javier Torres.
Hopefully it's Jujitsu is good.
Yeah.
Probably not as good as even Gracie's.
Hm.
Interesting.
I mean,
no one could say anything.
Look,
whatever everybody was on back then.
Fado was still beating everybody's ass.
So if they were all on the same shit,
Fado was still beating everybody up.
At the caveat to that is when he came
over to the u s he got dealt with with our
guts.
Yes.
Pretty quickly.
He struggles.
Brett Rogers,
right?
She'll a little bit with him.
Gets dealt with with Dan Henderson.
Anderson beat the fuck out of him.
[inaudible] foot Silva some up.
Yeah.
He beat her loss.
Tim Silvia,
Alaska Laskey.
He beat her Lawsky and affliction.
There was no testing and affliction.
That affliction thing was the wild,
wild west.
They were the,
I mean that was their teacher
does guys on a huge event.
Yeah.
Wasn't there when he got hit,
he was winning the fight.
He was whooping his ass
through a flying knee.
He was,
he was dealing with them in the standup,
and then he did something real stupid
and he got clipped with a haymaker.
That was such a crazy
knockout was such a cool,
cause I lost you front.
Kicked him to the gut.
It was a box in the mob.
He looked good.
Our Lawsky look good,
but he did something really nutty.
And then all of a sudden,
boom,
bom.
So fader Tim Silva under Lawsky,
Tim Silvia fight was amazing.
That was amazing.
But he looked like fate
or in that forever.
Like that was the,
and then the strike force.
Then you got a lead XC,
right?
And you got Brett Rodgers,
Dan Henderson for doom.
It was,
it,
was it a lead?
XC was in a,
was it an aliyah?
I see when he fought.
Uh,
Brett Rogers or no,
it was that strike a strike force.
I think it,
Strikeforce.
I think elite x was just Kimbo.
I don't think,
I don't think Fred Rogers was
the lead Xc Miko and crazy.
You think you're going
crazy because remember,
strike force,
uh,
Brett Rogers thought Overeem
when Overeem was ubering,
maneuver him.
Fuck hit him.
He didn't just,
he hit him with a leg kick like 15,
20 seconds into the fight.
One of those studding Hollins style
leg kicks and AC breaded Roger's face.
Like,
Oh shit,
that's not a snowflake.
No,
but Overeem hit him with some tech.
Nick hit him at that real technique that
that's why the argument for Steve Bay
being the best heavyweight of all time
is legit argument cause he's fought
clean.
He's never been,
you know,
it's my,
well he's defended the most,
the,
the UFC title,
which is the hardest title to defend
in terms of like historically no one's
defended it more than him.
He defended it three times.
Nobody else out beat too.
The only issue with that,
if you want to argue against the Bin,
I'm not,
I think he's the best
of all time hemmer cane.
But if you want argue
that you're going to say,
well the guy's he's beat
aren't in their prime.
That's a good point.
I think that's true.
What does a Scientology network,
what curious.
I just started everything.
Get the fuck out of here and there are,
they're advertising it on paramount.
Holy curious.
Do you have a pub?
Despots paramount.
Well they might be paid.
They got,
that's time.
Whose money or drive by
Scientology building.
I drove by last night.
Oh,
I got the test.
I want it in there.
I went to one of those
things that you did.
I held the cans.
Yeah,
I was a film and a TV show for CBS and
we were outside in San Diego and a while
we had some downtime.
They had this thing set up like a stress
test and you go and you hold onto these
cans and ask your questions.
I think I want to say Brian
did stand up in there,
so one asks me to go up there and do,
I either did stand up or like a Ted talk
or some shit in Scientology building
really?
And he did something weird to talk.
Well,
he was taken,
he was taken acting lessons with a guy
who was a rabid scientologist and then I
went to see Brian's acting
teachers sing songs from musicals,
not even a musical,
just the songs from the musical seconds.
Oh,
it was amazing.
It was great.
Me and Brian were high.
Is Jesus on the space shuttle?
I mean we were gone.
We were hugging each other.
Why it was going on.
We couldn't believe how ridiculous it was.
Like oh,
he either did like a motivational
talk or stand up there though.
Well he was,
you know,
which is a thing about acting classes.
A lot of my ex girlfriend,
one of her acting classes when I first
moved to La and I started dating,
this chick was an actress.
Her acting class was assigned technology
based act in class and apparently it's
really common.
There's a lot,
or at least it was at the time.
They get kind of up with
everything coming out with that.
Leah Ramy or whatever her name is.
Leah Remini.
Yeah.
It should be like the gigs up.
There's the internet,
you know,
podcasts when I'm with full of Shit.
It is.
Some people are just dying to get took.
They're just dying.
So I was like,
Yo,
Brendan,
you can be the next
fucking expendable seven.
You just got to jump into the,
I'd probably check it out.
What happens with girls with girls?
Apparently they come to them,
then they'll arrange like
boyfriend situations and weddings.
What happened was Tommy Cruz,
right?
Allegedly Katie Holmes,
allegedly,
she said,
fuck that noise.
Now she's with Jamie Foxx.
I worked for it.
He was was up to do,
do,
do shit.
Yeah.
Fox Lake down.
Damn.
I know she had fucking,
yeah,
Tom Cruise's laying low right now.
He apparently did some crazy ass stunt
for mission impossible where they had a
film at like a hundred times.
Did you see it now?
I heard Jamie hit it.
You didn't see it.
He jumped from a bit from building to
building that he does all his own stunts.
He's,
he is a bad ass.
Yeah.
He does all his own stunts.
It even when he's flying out of the hell
copies that he doesn't let anyone else
do it.
He's jumping from building to
building and he just barely misses it.
And from another building going
down is he lands flip first,
like into the building
and it's fucking ankle.
He broke his shit and he's like cut.
He's still like finishes the,
the take.
Yeah.
He's like [inaudible] [inaudible]
they had to cop going,
I need to see this.
He's a bit of a bad ass.
53.
I don't know man.
It's not young.
Kind of killing it though.
Listen,
that Scientology shit is real.
It's got him.
Vince.
We need to see this.
That el Hubbard shit got him caught.
They have so much power in Hollywood.
Uh,
how does that work?
Just Tom Cruise [inaudible] him and
John Travolta got this cord to get this.
Boom.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
that is crazy.
But you're Tom Cruise.
Look at this.
Yeah.
Oh,
she snapped his shit son.
Dan.
Mama see mission impossible.
Fuck is just because of that shit.
The kid finishes though.
Like a baller that's top gun.
So down.
Well you take the big bucks.
That's quite a jump to,
that's a quite a distance.
You know all of the scenes in
the helicopter and all that.
Where these hanging out?
Yeah.
That's all him and he's white,
white.
So that jump
man came one time camp camp.
They can get a rope.
Definitely had a that to,
that rope wasn't there.
He would have lived.
Right.
He made it.
He actually made it.
I help him.
You don't think they kind of like,
no,
no.
Watch it again.
Play it again.
I don't know if there's no rope and
he makes that this is the rope kind of
holding back the rubs.
Carrying them.
Oh,
so the rubs assisting him.
Yeah,
for sure.
All right.
Let me see.
Yeah,
for sure.
Look like the rope was behind him.
Yeah.
I thought the rope was just to catch
him cautionary because the rope,
like that's a weird thing that
the rope is assisting him.
Like,
man,
how do you even plan that?
That's kind of cool.
The real kind of catapult,
maybe assistant system
behind the rubs behind him.
No rope is not helping.
Oh,
and there's one above.
There's two.
Yeah.
Yeah,
you're right.
yeah,
yeah.
That's what it catches.
Mysteries and fall all
the way down and die.
Yeah.
Well that's what it's for.
That's what my point was.
I still think he has a
little bit of likability.
Achilles tendon tore off.
Yeah.
That looks like the ropes carrying him.
I bet he has drugs that we
don't even know about fixing it.
Yeah,
they get that from Mars.
Yeah.
Get that shit from they,
they pull it out of the fake
rocks that they pull out a Mars.
Here's another one.
Let me see.
The other ones hung on
the side of the plane.
Well that's fun.
And as he attached with a rope to yeah,
a little bit,
but still felt like shit.
He still really gets taken off.
He's hanging there.
That's nuts.
That's fucking niceness.
That's bananas.
That man's crazy rope though.
Right?
You know,
you taste surprised.
You'd be surprised at how hard it
is to hang for long periods of time.
You know,
when I hurt my shoulder
and I started hanging,
you know,
just holding onto a bar and hang.
I was stunned at how little weak you are.
How,
you know,
I do a lot of chips,
but I can't hold on for
more than like two minutes.
Something you have to condition for sure.
Really conditioned the
shit out of yourself.
You think you're going to like save
your ass and like hang on the side of a
plane for like,
you're screwed.
No,
you're dead.
You can't do it.
Oh Damn.
Lady pushed Kendall and said,
get out of my face,
bitch.
He got the camera too close to me.
But shokes on outside.
Um,
we had a fear factor episode
once where people had hang from.
Um,
there was a bridge and there was a bar
on the bridge was men and women and you
hung as long as you could hold it until
he dropped into the water and the girls
beat the guys.
How long were they hold lighter?
Not Very Long.
Not very minutes.
No,
no,
no.
I don't think anybody
beat like two minutes.
20 seconds or some shit.
Here we go.
Neiman Gracie ready to choke him,
mother fucker.
That's how I saw him fight was on that.
Uh,
uh,
Newark,
Med square garden card.
I think it's hens.
Those nephew.
Yes.
Correct.
Yeah.
He looks hyper aggressive.
He looks like a hen zone nephew.
Big Kid man.
And so the other guy has a hobby.
Oh,
tour Javier Torres.
Is that his name
to say Jane?
Yeah.
Did you see Roy McDonald ask him
about Astra to sign with Delta?
Yeah.
And Ben asked her wants to do it to
Ben asked her and still owes
fights with one fc though.
So they would have to do some
sort of a contract with him.
Yeah.
He owes two fights.
He goes two fights.
One MFC.
I know you're listing do us all a solid,
do all the hardcores assault,
let them out.
And so he had never going to let them out.
What they would do is they would cope
promote and it's possible you're not,
if he wants to fight in the UFC,
it's possible.
Oh hell.
Co-Promote with one FC,
you would have to,
it would have to be favorable conditions
with the UFC where like they just,
you know,
you can make some sort of a deal with
one of seeking stream at assumption.
They would have to be something or
they get them a piece of the revenue,
but it would have to be a very small,
the odds are already against them.
The sign with the assignment,
I know you gotta make this deal with
one FC and Dana is my kick rocks.
He should do is he should
get out of that contract.
That's what he did.
Just smoked two dude's real fast.
Just smash two dudes.
Just gimme two cans.
But he's the can crusher over there.
Rich Franklin's,
the guy who does the,
how dare you call him king crusher.
Matt Hume is to Matt Hume's
a part of when I was fellow.
What's up,
let's get this one of the
greatest fights all the time.
Role and my man.
Well who would you have in fight Woodley?
He's friends with,
with their trading partners.
I'd have them fight GSP first
and they'll have a fight.
Could be.
Do you think to GSP would take that fight
but nobody knows who asks.
Her name is outside of the core fans.
He said he would.
Could be.
Could be seven months ago.
70 yeah,
cause people start at 70 oh shit.
That is the fight I want to see.
It could be.
I want to be and no ass grin.
Oh me too screen Khabib is
what I would want to say.
That's my number one fight
because good luck taking GSP down.
Just good luck and good
luck standing with them too.
You know the,
the standup,
there's a big gap between
Ben Asker in Standup at GSP,
so this isn't a big gap
between Ben astrons grappling.
Just scrapping cap.
It's true.
It's amazing fight.
Wow.
There's a big gap between what has
grins is grappling and GSPS grappling.
Really big gap.
There's a big gap.
Then ask her shit.
Olympian legitimate and GSP.
Yeah.
GSP and aspirin.
Big Gap.
Yup.
If they wrestled,
that's great.
Okay.
[inaudible] out.
Good Woodley.
[inaudible] Woodley like GSP has
more takedowns in UFC history.
You're right.
I never had a guide at the level of
aspirin when it comes to wrestling,
he's a black belt in Jiu Jitsu.
No,
you're right.
If it gets to the ground,
the best,
the best guy he fought as
far as wrestling credentials,
who probably Josh Koscheck my,
yeah.
My thought would be that
GSP would never let,
oh,
he's doubled up to,
okay,
this dude's in trouble.
That's dudes in trouble.
It's crazy how leg locks are now making
their way much more prominently in in
MMA now you've seen much more leg lock
action unless you're focused on it.
I feel like,
okay,
you're fighting.
Dylan Dannis would have six
weeks to get ready for that.
You're not going to learn
the lace lock games.
That fear.
There's no way to know.
He got just can't get down
against a high level leg locker.
It's going to take you
four years to catch him.
Right.
These guys,
they're so far behind.
They're like,
Fuck Dylan.
Dance leg locked.
There's two ways.
Here it is.
Oh,
he's doing the right thing.
Yeah,
but his both legs are tied up.
Man.
He's so stuck.
That's such a gross feeling.
You can do it in two years.
It doesn't have to be four years average,
two years if you're with,
if you're with a good coach.
And I try to battle someone at like,
you know Henzel Gracie guy leg lock level,
it's going to take you at least two years
to to stalemate and least and he got
to be trained on every got out.
Yeah.
You got to post guys
guys aren't doing that.
Yeah.
And that's the thing with them and may
is a generally in MMA leg locks were
thought of as a,
as a,
as a technique.
You don't really ever need to even
focus on cause it just an MMA,
there were too many people have
gotten knocked out going for leg lock.
So the general consensus is don't
really worry about leg locks and MMA.
They're too dangerous anyways,
but there are um,
there you can't get knocked out.
It is dangerous.
And in my,
but they still work.
You just got to know which leg locked
positions are the safest and nothing else
is working out.
If you can't take the guy down,
he's beating your ass and it's the third
round you lost the first two rounds is
the last round that you
know going for a heel hook.
It might be a great idea and if you
practice them and if you're good at them,
you have hope in that last round.
You know what I mean?
Don't necessarily go for leg locks
right away because it is risky.
See if you could take them down first
so you can get on top and passed his
guard.
See if he can get his back.
If you can't and it's too dangerous,
then at some point your coaches and you,
you got to decide,
okay,
it's time to go to plan B.
Plan C and leg locks should
always be the last resort.
You know to remember Marco,
who else against Gary Goodrich?
Gary Goodrich was beaten
his ass the whole fight.
Last 45 seconds.
Marco,
who was pulled out a heel hook.
That's what we used to call them member.
I called Mary.
Who else looks well?
That's what we used to call heel hooks.
Hail Mary Helix,
the last resort.
It was last resort.
Paul Harvey's Kinda was the one that
really made it famous for a while,
but then he was getting fucked up.
When you thought Allen belts,
black belts,
it was just like,
I'm gonna sit down on this and
just punch you in the food.
You're really prepared for that.
He's also a black,
when you get to the point with
your leg locks where you can,
when you've been in the
fire for a couple of years,
two,
three or four years,
and you're really good at leg locks and
you're going against someone else at
that same level,
leg locks probably are,
aren't going to be the
deciding factor in that fight.
They're going to nullify so,
and then if you're going against a guy
who's really good at defending and he has
good wrestling and good punches,
shit,
that's your mind.
You might stay,
you might want to stay
away from leg locks.
Yeah,
it all depends.
It's the Matcha who did Belcher bring
in for his leg lock training because he
brought in someone really
dobby Ramos and dean lister,
Dean listers who brought him in and had a,
you know,
he said it was just two months,
one month,
two months of every day.
Them attacking his legs and that's all in,
that's all I needed.
You Know
Dobby Ramos is fighting 55 in the UFC,
right,
isn't he?
I believe he's funny things.
So five,
that's a bad motherfucker,
right?
That motherfucker,
his Jujitsu is top of the food chain.
Abu Dhabi.
In 2015 he had a sick flying arm bar and
one of his matches that were tourists
just fell down.
It makes me think that
his knee might be jacked
isn't,
he?
Might be a little shaky.
He looked like wobbly.
He fell down.
It looked weird.
Bill tour ratings have been rough.
Rough lately.
I haven't been rough,
rough,
so hopefully this one's better.
It's good for general.
You know when,
when bell toy and then UFC is
doing good for MMA in general.
It's good.
Well for MMA in general,
we need big cards.
I mean,
it really needs to get more people
watching and these are entertaining fights
and there's no reason why more
people shouldn't be watching.
I think they got a real problem with
her name and was just said this forever.
The name is stupid,
but even that's a nice c,
which is a great name.
Their rating suck too.
Sometimes.
Sometimes the name matters.
I don't think it matters at all.
I don't think it matters
it with bands and music.
Oh,
how did you,
you're like,
who do you in the boat?
Blowfish.
You liked that name?
Yeah,
I do.
Yeah.
Where are they today?
Flogging Molly.
You like that?
I do.
It doesn't bother me fish
because it works.
Smashing pumpkins.
If you weren't used to it,
you would think if they never existed in,
it's a great ball out of all of us.
Don't realize that I'm with you.
I wish you a flogging Molly pumpkin smash
brothers is one of my favorite bands
of all time.
I know,
but if they never existed,
and I told you my new bands
called smashing Pumpkins,
you would say,
dude,
you got to change your mind.
Oh,
I would love it.
I fuck fucking love
Billy Corgan to cool motherfucker.
Man.
Let me tell you,
I had him on the pot.
Yeah,
he was great on the punch.
So normal.
I love that guy.
The form.
We should go that the form in October.
Let's do it.
Let's make it happen.
You know texting,
can you text me?
You Texted Billy Corrigan.
Buck.
Are you able to take some assistant?
Damn.
You know that's one podcast.
I wish I would have been here for God
that went in the Paul Stanley one.
Shit,
I wish I could have been here.
Was that you had tool fan.
Do you ever even meet
Maynard diver in shoes?
Your man?
I never met Maynard.
Not they would get along cause he's
a Jujitsu trainer's a Jujitsu freak.
I know his face belt but I'm
pretty sure he's got his brother.
Yeah,
he's a pro bono long time ago,
but he's a,
he comes in town for seminars.
He goes to dynamics like Henry Akins,
his place.
Yeah he does.
He goes to seminars down there.
Jim.
I know his friends very well.
I just don't know him.
He's a great guy.
Maynard is one of the
smartest people I know,
man.
Wicked smart wrestling league.
No,
no.
That's Billy Corgan.
Billy Corgan,
the Nwa.
He's said it.
He's balls deep into loves progress.
Does he own t and t?
One of those?
He wrote,
Oh,
look at this.
Look at this.
I said,
brother,
it game over.
That's it.
That's a rap song.
Tappity tap.
I'm telling you that we're
getting all submissions tonight.
That's guys,
whoa.
Lavato and Gerald Harris is
going to be a difficult one.
I bet you it's all super excite.
They're very good.
Yeah,
I'm good too.
I might be over good.
The whole frickin.
Oh No.
Billy Corgan,
he was,
he was digging wrestling.
I just got the pro wrestling.
Loves it.
He's a funny guy,
man.
He's a really smart dude.
He's such a such a mom's
Mainers on into progress on,
but what Mainer is into
his own.
He owns a vineyard and a restaurant.
He's fucking crazy into why they talked
about wine for a solid hour on your
blog.
Just
like God damn it,
Bro.
I thought you were going to
say the nice thing and say,
yeah,
it was interesting.
That's a fascinating guy,
but I'm all set on what?
He's got.
The clamp.
Oh,
you're screwed man.
Yeah,
that's a tight one,
baby.
You see how he manipulates those legs?
That guy's done that too.
A lot of fucking people when this point.
He could've,
he could've,
he could've defended right here if you
would have just brought us a legs up and
hooked his own left leg and turn away.
Yeah.
He could've just went like this.
Just to annoy you.
When guys do that though.
You go to the,
you have to go to the bank.
Yeah,
it,
but you've got to do
that before he grabs you.
But when a guy grabs his legs,
do you still go to the impaler?
I've seen you.
I,
I rarely do an arm triangle.
Not Mounted.
Rarely I stay in them out.
Why do you stay in the
mountain on one side your side?
Because that one defense
I was just telling you,
you can't do it from the mind
that stops all arm triangles.
There's,
you're forced to go to another submission,
which you're forced to take the back.
You're kind of give up your back.
But the guy who was about to get top wins,
he gets another chance guys on your back.
But that choke was in deep.
When you um,
when you tap a guy from the mount or
when you go to the arm triangle from the
mount,
what percentage of effectiveness do
you think it is in comparison to go on?
Like,
like a clock,
like fully out.
You May,
there may be some added
Torque and the twist,
but if you go butter mount,
which is putting your butterflies
on top and you extend,
you get,
you don't need it,
you don't need to get on the side.
So it,
is it just a new movement
that you have to master?
Well it all depends,
you know,
on the,
on your opponent,
if he knows this defense,
someone puts you in a arm triangle.
Like this is caught,
I would all have to do is
just bring this leg up.
Like dude,
get inverted and Gopro and there's
no way you're going to tap.
See this is a thing.
I've seen you separate guy's legs when
you were really into the impaler and I
know I've done it to guys
that aren't very good,
but I've seen you when you were
really into the impaler for awhile.
No one did that though.
The inhaler being,
do you know when dibs?
No one did the defense?
The defense is,
yeah,
the defense of grabbing your leg.
Nobody did that and not back in the day
because everybody was laying down the
way he did the arm triangle where he's
like laying inside control flat on his
back.
You obviously works.
People are tapping,
but it's easy to defend
if the guy knew it.
If the guy sees it coming,
it's like as soon as,
as soon as this arms in trouble,
boom.
You're right here.
That's an interesting,
maybe I'm confusing you with
somebody else I had because I know,
I know during your,
when you,
there was a whole run when a lot of us
were into the impaler and then you also
started putting it down where you would
put the Shin to the hip and really
stretch a guy out.
But
Jesus,
what?
Jesus said,
get that cut.
Oh Shit.
Who's cut is that damn cage
warriors earlier today?
Oh my God,
that's crazy.
That's an eyebrow.
That's full iron t his skull.
That's,
that's one of the biggest I've ever seen.
Um,
Jesus Cruz.
I remember arguing with somebody
about it when someone was saying that,
um,
you can't separate a
guy's hands like that.
I'm like,
how long do you think
you can hold your hands?
We need Mattson here and now we do.
You can put Matt,
Matt,
but here's the thing.
I have new Matt's coming so
we can do that right here.
All you need is cameras that when
he done straight the defense dot,
you could dive right in the middle of map.
He says,
because you don't know
what we're talking about.
We want to understand if
you're going to have that,
because there's new mats coming in
because the mats a that I'm getting from
Fuji,
the grappling ones are too slippery.
They're,
they're not,
they don't have any texture to them.
Zebra,
I'm getting new zebras,
best I Z,
but have zebra in my office
getting all new zebras.
But Fuji makes a real good one
with a texture for striking.
So for kicking and stuff,
I need some texture.
I can't,
but on the ground it's fine.
So I'm going to take the ones from the
ground and you need the texture for
passing too.
If you get all sweaty,
you need the texture.
Because at the mats I have now no tabs,
nobody complains that they purchased
slippers for wrestling cause the maths I
have met are made for wrestling
shoes and wrestlers have shoes.
So it's not an issue.
When you're going barefoot
and doing Jujitsu and it
gets sweaty after like three
or four rounds,
passing becomes impossible.
It's like passing on ice.
Is it hot in here?
So having a heart attack,
cause it's harder than you guys are
sweating to having a heart attack.
But if you feel the zebras they're made,
they're made for barefoot,
uh,
traction.
We've got a thermostat
in here seeking glory.
Hebrews is what they put in my,
my gym.
But um,
my gym at home.
Yeah.
But these out here,
the Fuji is the smooth ones.
Man.
It's not good for kicking.
Like Gwen,
I'm kicking,
I'm slipping around a lot.
Like I don't,
well for specially for
spinning and I spin,
I need,
I need traction.
I have to have something where
I could push my foot off.
I can't,
like with round kicks,
you can kind of get away with
it because of your foot slips.
Your whole body's just kind of
moving and we're kind of match.
You got to come in and you
already got it all hooked up.
Yeah.
It's already that they're out there.
I'll show him.
Yeah.
The other Fujis full of she's,
but they're tatami mats.
So they have,
it's a pretty strong texture.
It's a strategy.
Decide,
go.
Those were the over zebra.
Um,
Jimmy Pedro.
Oh,
got you.
Me Pedro went over to there and uh,
he did my first place.
He,
you know,
Olympic judo master is a bad motherfucker.
He did my other place and so,
you know,
when he moved there,
I just went with him there.
Um,
I liked him.
I just don't think they're
the right thing for what I do.
But the tatami ones with the heavy
texture is perfect for kickboxing.
I mean you really,
I need,
especially if I'm really sweaty and I'm
throwing like spin kicks and shit like
that,
I am not in the mood to blow my knee out.
A lot of wine.
A lot of my students play the word blame.
The mats when they have a bad day and I'm
sitting there and they're having a bad
day.
They're like these fucking maps.
These maps,
they all get together in the corner.
Yeah.
It's the maps,
right?
Yeah.
When are we getting new
maps coach or shoes,
bro.
Guilty too fucking mad brawls.
He's fucking Matt.
They'd make fun of the HQ.
Matt.
That's funny.
I used to,
but now no more.
In two weeks I get new mats were everyone.
I just had um,
pads put down with a cloth strap,
a nylon top stretched across a member.
We've got those dudes to do it.
Yeah.
Those atoms are switched.
We're done.
Yeah.
Those can get slippery.
Super slippery.
It was loose too.
It's like,
the problem with that was it wasn't tight.
So like remember the old headquarters
for a Gracie Jujitsu in Torrance?
Yes.
They had that massive floor.
The green
tarp tighten up the top.
That's exactly what I had.
So it was like,
it's never told so slippery.
Never tight.
It's never really tight.
Dude.
Am I crazy to think but baders the
dark horse to win the heavyweight.
He when it book Bader is still very,
very good and not the king.
Most non king mo can fucking punch and
he at one point in time at least was a
world class wrestler.
Chemo was a beast of a wrestler.
I still is fun.
One of the best I've ever seen.
But he's,
he's had some injuries
man and he had really,
really bad staff.
Yeah,
I think the staff got them at least twice.
I want to,
I know he got it once.
I want to say he got it twice real bad.
He had a real bad staff like come on man.
Baders probably at the top of his
game right now is in his prime.
When he beat Phil,
I was like,
Holy Shit.
He beat Phil Davis and he took
them down a bunch of times.
It's like,
look,
he's the top of his game.
He's at the top of his game.
You look at the heavyweight division,
the tournament baders my
dark horse man Bader is a,
he is a legit world class fighter that
is actually probably add is best right
now.
I would say that Ryan Bader
right now is in his prime.
Here's the thing though,
even in his prime,
he's not at the level of John and that
was over in the UFC and the UFC who is,
well maybe Danielle's spin,
I mean DC,
DC's,
DC's clothes,
you know,
DC put up a good fight the first time
and the second time it was a good fight
until John had put up a better fight.
He did.
The speculation is a John barely
trying on train for two hours,
literally show at all.
That's how good he is.
Correct.
But when John Fought Ryan,
you were like,
okay,
this is a gap.
He was able to him like a baby,
there's a gap that you go,
Ooh,
how are you going to cross that gap?
You know what I mean?
Even if you're a DC,
you gotta be thinking,
you know,
I love DC.
Even with dcs,
we thinking,
how can I cross that gap?
Ice 40 it's true.
He's going to be for,
it's true.
It's true.
I look,
oh,
I'm,
I can't disagree with you,
but
DC at least was competitive in that
fight before he got head kicked.
It was a competitive fight.
He was putting a lot of pressure on John.
It was interesting.
This is a good card,
right?
But John set them up.
It is a good card.
Ooh,
Paul daily versus John Fitch.
Jesus Christ.
That's a good fight,
man.
Holy Shit.
Aaron Peko juicy.
His last winter when that
left hook to the chin,
it was like a shovel hook.
Fucking.
He's a beast.
He's so God damn.
I think losing that first fight,
it's probably the best thing that
could've ever happened to him.
He doesn't train with you.
Does he hear that first fight he did.
He's a 10th Planet Guy,
right?
Not Anymore.
Oh no,
he was.
He then after he lost,
I think they blamed it on the talent.
Dennis,
I was like,
I don't know,
200 I just never came back.
Dylan,
Dennis,
his tattoo is fucking sweet.
Like whoever did that.
That's like a real artist.
They nailed that dragon.
Yeah,
it's really good,
man.
That's like Aaron Dellavedova style.
Like look how good that dragon is.
My like what I'm talking about too is
not just the image but the way it's lined
up.
Like the,
the,
the use of space.
Like when you see a
real good tattoo artist,
one of the things they do is they really,
they,
they fill up the space the right way
with the right amount of darkness.
Right.
Amount of lightness.
That good contrast.
Yeah.
Body they are of the body.
It fits perfect.
Sometimes I wish I could go back.
Cause now pet,
I feel like tattooers are so much better.
They're so good.
The styles are so much different.
It just hit like the Prius
of tattoos instead of,
you know,
it's way better than laser that shit off.
You know?
Fuck that.
I don't know.
I wouldn't go.
I'd go with none.
None.
I love tattoos man.
I do too.
I feel like I have to cover him.
I believe you.
I don't know why,
but I do.
I love that Dylan Dannis style of Tattoo.
That's a dope tattoo.
That's my favorite style of those
big ass modern Japanese looking.
I always cover my man.
I mean I run if I'm doing stand up,
I always cover.
I do for standup ashamed.
Yeah.
Probably the only time people see
and when I'm not is on this podcast.
Honestly,
if it's one of them,
well no.
Even during my shows I cover him.
Wayins Wayne's,
I'll wear a tee shirt.
That's one thing that UFC has been doing.
It's bold cotton making cool t
shirts for each Rebekah maker.
Cool t shirt for each place you go to,
you know.
Have you been wearing those?
Sometimes they won't.
Usually more of the pasta on time usually,
but I wore the Boston one.
Boston,
they made a dope one was green like a
bumblebee looked like a bumblebee with
gloves on at the UFC.
He's like backstage who is like
the head Honcho walking around.
Is there someone above Dana that's walking
around and hanging out backstage or a
statement that the 12 Dana's
always running the show for sure,
but because they're like,
oh shit,
that's the Golden Snitch,
right?
Novitsky he's the guy.
Everyone's kind of like,
well,
no,
no.
He's mean.
He's like running the show.
No,
no,
no.
Just walking around,
hanging out.
No,
there's nobody above Dana walking around,
hanging out.
No.
Dean street,
President's man.
An Ari is so busy that bitch on backstage.
Oh No,
no.
But when he comes there,
it's very brief and he comes for the
fights or he comes to the weigh ins.
He goes,
do you out fucking busy.
That dude must be,
he's in and out.
You're just still,
the UFC says side chick.
Yeah.
Not even.
He just gets it.
It's a big company.
It's a,
it's a business.
They put together with a bunch of
celebrities bought into it and you know,
it's a real big deal,
but
a lot of people bought into it.
I would have to look at it and athletic.
A lot of code is part owner of the UFC.
Well,
I don't,
I don't ask questions,
honestly.
I really don't ask a lot of quick.
I also make chair.
I've been working there forever.
I ask almost no questions.
This is what I asked.
What are you gonna do with this guy?
What are you gonna do with it?
And he wanted to latch
up and he'll be like,
you can't tell anybody this.
This is where ward.
And I'm like,
Oh shit.
Oh Shit.
That's the questions I asked for data.
I never asked questions about
business or who bought this.
Or I don't have enough room in my brain
to give a fuck about other people's
business.
I have zero interest in
the people's business.
I mean literally zero,
especially with the UFC.
I don't give a fuck.
I just want to know who's fighting,
who was fighting knew,
what are you going to do?
I'm not like,
how much is this Guy gonna make?
What percentage is he owned and who is he,
what's he doing?
And how's he gonna make us money back?
And what kind of financial returns,
investments you're going to go,
I don't give a fuck about you.
But when they see those
celebrities or owners,
it's just like a business.
But if they don't,
they might even not be into the UFC.
It's just as far as money,
like estimate people are into getting
famous people to invest in shit too.
It's a fun thing.
Oh cool.
Jay is that ll cool Jimmy Kimmel?
I mean it's just,
there you go.
There's Mike Dot Trend.
He owns it too.
They don't have any sense.
Mike Bell Trout and get the best
fucking mustache in the game at 11.
Owns a piece of the pie.
How cow about nick knew we'll get a shot.
Anthony Kiedis.
There we go.
Calvin.
Dan's a piece of the UFC.
Damn Damn.
Damn.
Um,
so a lot of people bought into it
like what the fuck is she
doing in the fight game?
So what they do is they,
you know,
they probably,
everybody chips in a little bit.
So strengths give them stock.
They just give them stock.
Michael Bay,
pretty sure he showed that didn't chip in.
I don't think they chip
it up and get his dog,
nor will they give them stock
for cause they own the business,
right?
They're not.
Then I can cast from those guys.
I don't think,
well,
what then?
Why would they do that?
Why would they give him a piece
of the business for no reason?
They'd have to give them money.
I don't know.
See,
this is why I don't want them to do this.
This is why I don't do,
I don't like doing it.
We're doing
now,
but what I'm saying is I don't like
wondering who's paying what or how they're
doing and wanting to hear about it.
Now we,
we'd like it.
You know what?
That's one of the things I've
found as I've gotten older.
Specialty is to concentrate on
less things like God bless you.
Other things,
just put them aside,
put it aside.
Concentrate on less things.
You can get better at the
things that you really enjoyed.
There's only so many
things you could think of.
There's only so many things.
If you spend your time worrying
about other people's nonsense,
you're robbing yourself.
You think it's fun,
but it's really a big fat distraction.
You know what it is.
It's not even to your life,
right?
So you're thinking about things that
are going on in other people's lives and
you're doing it because you're
not giving 100% to your life,
and there's some stress involved in that.
And so distract yourself from that stress.
You concentrate on other people's lives.
It's a very common thing.
Do you like you can have arguments.
You have a fake arguments with myself.
Oh,
he used to do that all the time.
I used to pretend someone
would say this back to me.
I was to be,
well,
I will.
I fuck you.
I'm going to say this back to you.
And then sometimes it would be with a
dude and then I would run into him to talk
to him,
thinking we're going to
have this big audience.
I'll say,
man,
I'm sorry I fucked up all this shit.
And then I abandoned it immediately.
I think there's so much of how
people interact with each other.
It could be just way different with just
a little shift in how we talk to each
other and how we think about it.
You did that last night I was
doing to set the laugh factory in,
uh,
we were talking about
Santiago and Theo Vaughn.
I was going,
you know,
in between them I had this whole
dialogue in my head cause they were like,
oh we got to stay on what you said,
that'd be cool.
And as soon as I got done I was like,
God,
that fucking Santino thought that sucked
and this and I'm like literally go and,
and you come to the back.
He was a nice guy ever.
Santina was a very nice guy.
He's fucking destroyed last night.
He's a funny dude because like the
young guys that are coming up that I go,
oh look at you.
He him him and feel last night,
bat back to back.
I was like,
you motherfuckers are monsters.
Have you seen his bid?
He does about the rock.
You've got to ask him to Contino yes.
Cause he doesn't,
he's,
he's has so much material
that he stopped doing it.
I guess he'll do it,
but if you bring it up,
he'll do it.
I asked him to do it one night.
He did it for us in the or.
Dude,
he,
I don't know who said,
Oh,
you got to see him.
He's so,
he does a lot of my shows.
Well,
redhead,
redhead.
Okay.
Um,
he's um,
he's fucking funny guy.
He's,
I'm doing,
I think he's on my show
on the 24th in Chicago.
Yeah,
he's doing that with me in Chicago.
Him and Tony hit him.
His elbow header.
That's a ridiculous show.
Him and I walked from laugh factor,
the comedy store last night
and he's a chatty Cathy.
She clearly could talk really good dude.
I'd love that guy.
I love Santinello and Theo Vaughn,
I love him too.
He's so original.
Two killers,
man.
So,
so death when they go home last night
and the CEO I was supposed to do as
podcasts,
but it just,
it never,
I dunno when I connect you guys,
he wanted you on there.
We went back and forth.
I still want to do it,
but it just,
it just didn't,
it just didn't help him.
I'll get,
I'll get ahold of the last few weeks.
We've been fucking crazy.
So with your knee operation and all that,
they have each other's numbers.
Yeah.
He's so funny,
man.
Ask him better too.
How about,
how about his boy was with him last night.
I don't think he knows as much about Theo.
Stand up and feels just sucking every
fucking breath out of that place.
Just destroying.
And he goes,
man,
he's good.
Like Theo.
He's like,
yeah.
and he's doing really good down there.
I'm like,
yeah man,
he's a fucking killer.
Well,
you know,
the thing is,
Theo has really come into his
own over the last two years.
Uh,
and that's,
I met him right around the time
it was really pop in for him.
He was always really good.
Like everybody thought
he was always funny,
but he,
he hit some new level.
I remember me and Adam,
the booking agent at the comedy store.
Yeah,
we were in the hallway and Theo
was murdered or ring and w we,
he got offstage and I went up to Adam.
I go duties on another level.
He hit some new stride.
He goes,
yeah,
right.
Like we remember like recognizing this
moment where Theo was in some new space.
He was in some weird like
original space everywhere I go,
like I was just in Calgary and uh,
they go,
who else is good out there?
I went have you feel everyone
I give three Oh Vons.
Like No.
I'm like how do you guys not,
he should be just shit rolling talent.
You can sales.
It's one of those things too.
My God,
how are you guys?
Not just people are gonna know.
Yeah keep an eye on those two dudes
are like the next Thompson Guerra.
Correct.
You guys didn't know Michael Che is.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
His Netflix specials.
Fucking high level as a model.
It's called Michael chain matters dude.
He's got this Jesus bit where he
talks about how Jesus was a carpenter.
I'm not going to ruin the bib.
And he's saying he like he,
he must've sucked cause cause if he
would have been good that would have been
pieces of furniture.
I mean might do is big.
He's really good.
He does the high level high.
Last night just released
a special on Netflix.
I didn't know you still doing standup.
Uh,
James,
your boy come James.
Yeah.
Yeah,
he just did.
Yeah.
He's been doing standup.
He does like I know you
used to be on a killers.
I didn't know that.
We basically were amateurs together.
We're basically just starting to get paid.
And I signed with my manager and I got
my manager to sign with Kevin and w like
I have a,
I'm in a small management company and
he has a few clients that have been with
them for more than 20 years and
two of them are me and Kevin.
Is this,
you and Kevin is this,
sorry,
I'm in Boston or la.
It was in New York.
Oh,
from Boston to New York
because of my manager.
And then I hooked my manager up with
Kevin and then Kevin and I are pretty
close.
Yeah,
I know that.
That's what I watched his special,
cause I think Bryant told me,
he's like,
dude,
he was killed.
He was a killer.
And I think you told me that too.
So I've never seen a stamp.
I've,
I've watched it on youtube
but then his special,
it's good with,
you know what it is,
man.
It's like at this point he's just so busy.
You know,
he's got his TV show and he's
always doing before Kevin can wait.
He was always his other TV
show that went on forever,
you know?
That's,
and he was like a main guy on that show.
So no,
no.
I mean as an actor,
I mean as a writer.
Oh.
So it wasn't just,
Oh dude.
He wrote everything with those
guys and he's super wrote a lot.
He rewrote a lot.
He went over all the scripts.
And the reason why the show was so good,
it's because it was a talent
that staff are writers,
talented actress,
Leah Remini.
He was very funny.
There was a lot of funny
people on the Shell.
Patton Oswald was really
going on the show.
He's great.
But more than anything it was
like Kevin is like a driven dude.
Like he,
he gets super obsessed
about doing the right.
Like he would,
he would go over lines
but he eats it like this.
Like he's,
he's a craftsman.
Like he's trying to break it down.
You know,
he's trying to figure it out but he just
doesn't do the amount of standup now
that he used to when he was a start.
Now how could you can't,
there's no way we could,
that's why you didn't think that he was
doing it anymore because there's no way
he could do the kind of standup where
you'd be everywhere all the time.
He just didn't have that time.
Yeah,
you're doing a sitcom.
It's your sitcoms switched.
We were writing.
Fuck Dude,
that's so much work.
Hey Shannon talked about that too
cause he would write everything,
overlook every episode.
Then she can't do both.
Think,
think about some of the
shit that we've done.
Like that cartoon about you getting
kidnapped by the Mexicans and then we'll
fill you up with drugs and
turn it into a sex slave.
But Dick's pump that we
didn't write a goddamn thing.
No,
we were just two friends refund,
giggling,
being ridiculous.
And it turns into a cartoon
and it's fucking hilarious.
Like you watched that cartoon.
It's hilarious.
We have it so much easier.
If they were doing a sitcom,
we'd had meetings,
we'd have to do a run
through for the network.
The network would give a stupid notes.
We did a,
I know,
and it was insane.
It was a nightmare.
Fucking nightmare from day one.
It's not a nightmare.
I have to deal with a little bit of a
little bit now because my showtime show
and below the belt,
you're shouts at least not scripted.
No.
See that's the thing.
So with the animal,
when things are scripted,
it's shit gets weird.
See,
because what they're doing with
you is very talent dependent.
They're dependent upon your personality.
That's what people want to see.
The more they let you go,
the better the show is going to be.
They realize that.
And you see it in the show now,
right?
Yeah.
But if you're,
if you're on us a show where
they're creating the dialogue,
everybody's got to say it was in there
and everybody's got their own little
fucking opinion about how this should
go and that should go and you don't want
to hear their shit and they think you
suck and everybody's going back and forth
and then the network comes in and they
don't want to get their greasy pause on
it.
Everybody wants to get their
fucking just in the soup.
They all want to get their flavor flavor,
a little bit of flavor.
Everybody literally wants to
add their DNA to the script.
I've,
I've seen people try to change
things just to justify their job.
They have to have an opinion.
Everybody has to have an opinion.
Like I just think she's
not dressed hot enough.
They have these conversations.
We need to,
we need a black guy,
we need a black guy and noise.
And then you listening to some executive
that doesn't know shit about writing.
They're not writers.
They just decide they want to have some
sort of say and they think they know the
business because they'd
been working as an executive
fucking up shows for about five,
six years,
so they've got to experience fucking
up shows so they think they can fuck up
your show and fix it.
It'd be a nightmare to do
all that and do stand up.
We need a gay neighbor.
We have to advocate and kind of get
a gauge for to me to stay neighbor.
Big,
silly,
bold.
Well now it's going to transgender.
Transgender.
Have you heard of transracial?
All do.
Thank God you guys remind me of this.
There's a new podcast,
there's a new documentary on Netflix
about that lady who was white.
Black?
Yes.
And it is at,
what's it called?
What's it called?
I forget,
but you watch it.
Poor Lady.
No,
you feel bad.
The Rachel Rachel Dozer,
right to call it the racial divide.
The Rachel Dolezal is her name.
Dozzle Doughlas though her name now.
She changed her name to like some
soup and she still want to be black.
Super African sounding names.
No spoiler alerts.
I mean,
you can look this shit up,
but they basically like,
she goes on,
she writes a book sales 500 of them.
It goes terrible stress to make money
because the black community doesn't accept
her.
The white community doesn't Septa.
So she writes this book and then at the
end you see her taking her braids out
and like,
oh damn,
she's going back to white.
But she doubles down with Conda style.
Comes out with like an Afro Change.
A name like fucking what's
the racial divide?
What is her a new name?
It's something crazy.
Like from the motherland.
Yes.
Cherice Gerald Harris
was always super jacked.
He's,
it looks good.
It looks like he's a good choice.
Shit.
There's going to be a great fight,
man.
Yeah.
Carol Harrison,
Rafael Lovato.
There it is.
The a married Diallo.
Oh,
that's the chain.
That's syrup soup.
Campbell.
Yeah.
That's super normal.
That makes sense for a white girl.
Um,
do you know Gerald Harris does stand up?
Apparently.
It's really fun.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I haven't seen,
I saw like a very short clip of
him when he was first starting out.
Oh yeah,
he's a funny guy.
Did something that could be
like an eminent comedy tour.
You Gerald Harris.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Who else is,
what else is doing it?
Adam Hunter.
He's like,
no,
he's a cowboy.
He was a really good restaurants,
but he's still in the MMA community.
Yeah,
he's in the community.
His,
his show was fucking good man.
And he's a hilarious comic.
He's a really good joke writer.
Like a one liner type dude.
Very good at that.
He's a good dude too.
So that would be him.
And he wrestled.
I think he coaches wrestling too.
It doesn't need to do
some shit with Einstein.
Einstein,
I think they to do a podcast together
and then they don't even want to workout
and then hand out.
They'll started doing it
and that's what caused the trouble.
Always caused the trouble.
I've never met him.
And that's the is for you,
I'm sure know.
Ran into him.
He
brings you up though.
He calls you Brendan Schwabie.
That makes sense.
Your big
back.
No,
I've never met him.
One of the funniest guys to ever live.
It's a funny,
still fuzzy.
Oh,
have you seen this?
That hand up on the Rhonda
Show when he does the sketches,
Robert Deniro,
he does the heat scatch.
He's got the rocky three sketch.
He's got an incredible hulk.
Sketch the statutes off the chart.
This is brilliant.
This the one is to take on snow.
Michael Bisping,
Michael Bisping and him in a,
in a fucking parody of snatched
it is hilarious.
Don't channel.
He had his own show and eat.
It's a talk show where he brought,
he's brought it and he's
had a Henner Henner Gracie,
frank shamrock.
He's the time.
He's the host,
but it's not a race.
It's like a podcast,
but at the show.
And he rushes his guests.
He's the premise of the show.
If he's better than the guests and he's
going to crush it and he smashes you.
He had frank shamrock on and I asked him,
I go,
did you,
did you bring up his snaggletooth not,
you know,
and uh,
and he's,
he brought it up for 30 minutes.
I love Frank Shamrock,
but he fixed it though.
He's got braces.
I got braces,
my teeth look like
freights braces.
My teeth were just as bad as frank,
so I had to get braces as
an old man to Invisalign.
Brian's doing Invisalign.
They're not getting better.
Brian's had Invisalign
for like four months now.
Check this out.
Took him out.
His teeth are fucked up.
Tell him snatching,
tell him a letter.
Let it go.
Oh,
here it is.
Snatching.
Can we play this on the podcast?
And that's uh,
who's the other?
Kip.
Kip Cole.
He's a grappler.
Dale Kit Dale.
This is great.
Shakes himself.
When you put them in a range,
they're like a dog fight.
I,
we've lost Vinnie.
Magallanes.
Shh.
You're going to have to repeat that.
He's good,
right?
You need McElfresh.
Well,
where the fuck did you lose him too?
And I as if he's a fucking pair of Khakis
and I asked him if he's not his fights
going on.
We'll come back to this long sketch.
That's a long sketch.
We'll come back to it.
Let's watch like it's 40 minutes long.
This fight on the show is 40 minutes.
Lavato and Gerald Harris here,
this shit's going down.
This is an interesting fight to me.
Lavato was one of the best
Jujitsu guys right now in MMA.
I love Oklahoma money can fuck dudes
upstanding and speaks Portuguese,
right?
Oh,
crazy.
Flying knee.
Do you go to the ground with them?
It's probably not a good idea.
Let's see what happens here.
You might get tied it up.
I thought Joe Retired.
He did for a bit and I,
but he's back.
This is is coming from the
EOC and then Simon Belt Tours.
I do not remember.
[inaudible] has got a
really good guard too,
so he's in here.
He's in danger,
right?
Yeah.
I mean he's got his legs closed.
Don't cheer was playing this game.
This is not a wise move maneuver.
It's probably going to end right here.
Yeah.
You don't realize what is left.
Elbows out.
He's good.
He's safe right here.
His legs are tied around the triangle,
man.
If he puts in that,
if he triangles his legs,
even with both arms and,
oh,
there it is.
It's over.
It's done.
That's done.
Tapped.
What the fuck was,
you know what I'm saying?
But they don't know.
They don't know.
They'll know this guy's level of Jujitsu.
They have an idea.
They think they can survive.
You can't.
He has knockouts too though.
Does she was upset.
It was kind of bummed out that
he didn't get the choke him,
but he could show that he does.
He can do that too.
But the level on the ground is so high.
When's the last time you saw
this many high level Jujitsu Guy?
Just submit first round,
right?
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Crazy good on beltway.
Now frank just kept the nine off.
Jumped to half guard,
Bro.
Like a pageant.
If he snapped faders arm too.
Shit.
Think about that friend Sylvia Nogueira.
What if he breaks faders arm and
we'd go get the fuck Outta here.
He has arguably one of the best cars in
the history of the heavyweight division.
Got Night Guards,
right?
Yeah.
Frank.
Frank journals.
Guard it is.
It is better.
But Frank's got a wicked fucking
guard man at that beautiful swing.
Ooh Bam.
He just let him know.
He wraps it up to God.
Damn.
That was tight.
Can Filthy.
Beautiful.
Do you like the smell and
look at the swim right here.
Boom.
Perfect.
Um,
do you like this way?
I think that all the time,
that's often arm crush.
That's how your legs will be often failed.
I'm crushed to the arm bar.
Right.
It's perfect.
Do you prefer it like that
or do you know for the legs,
that's when the legs are,
the legs aren't perfect,
meaning ankles are crossed
over the far elbow or shoulder.
Um,
that's perfect.
Right.
Dot.
Sometimes you just can't have it perfect.
So that is if Gerald Harris
would have had a good corkscrew,
a good hitchhiker,
he could've got out.
But uh,
you gotta have that and then chamber
ready to go and you got to rep it a couple
thousand times.
That's a very technical move.
Rembert remember when Carl
prissy and fought Matt Serra?
Remember that?
And Carl prison,
one of them almost had an armbar.
Carl almost had Matt.
And then Matt hit a perfect
corkscrew hitchhiker out of it.
So if you have those in
the chamber ready to go,
uh,
the legs need to be perfect.
Yeah,
that's what I was thinking,
that the left shoulder had more mobility
than it would if you had a cut over.
But it was so tight.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's interesting how some guys like chew,
they get a certain way of doing it like
that and then they choose that over the
other way.
They'll just sign it.
Yeah,
right there.
There was no,
if he want to try to get it perfect first,
he would have lost it.
But you know how some guys do that though.
Some guys will choose like a specific
way to lock up an arm bar or an arm
triangle and it might not even
be like the most effective,
but they do it that way so much.
They get it locked down.
There's so many variations
that you can hit that armbar.
You know,
you could hit it belly down on your side,
on your back.
You know,
ideally if you're controlling the action,
you're going to get that arm bar and
you're going to be on your back and he's
going to be on his back and spider web.
If you're controlling everything but shit,
the guy's a beast and starts moving.
You got to move with them and you gotta
you gotta make sure that you have the
skills to get that arm bar in any
of the positions in the scramble.
Do you remember when people were almost
always doing the rear naked choke with
the palm on the back of the head?
It was almost always of hiding it.
You're saying instead of
doing the chronic away,
it was always palm to the back of the
head and then it switched and everybody
was like,
Oh yeah,
that's way better if you can get it in
the gloves and sometimes it's hard to get
the gloves fate or Nick Emelianenko
tracked down by FBI agents at Bella
[inaudible] 98 what they've been in and
out of his hotel room for the last few
days apparently to why is the former
owner of Bella tour was Michael Cohen.
What?
And there might be some Russian collusion.
They're going to find pictures
of him and Trump has this real,
holy shit this,
we reported it from here.
I mean,
I'm not digging it.
So your other places had it too.
What if Trump and fit fade or colluding?
That's crazy.
Boy Or fade or in Putin?
No Cutler boys.
You were saying before about Invisalign.
Invisalign does work.
The thing is no,
he probably,
he probably takes him out.
You got to keep him in and once
you take them out for life,
you got at night,
you got to sleep with the routine.
Yeah,
you got to,
people get lazy.
I get lazy.
So you're supposed to do it every night.
Um,
if you go three or four nights
without using the retainer,
your teeth go back to the eye.
They used to be shit.
Just go with the metal
for like three months.
Even with when you're
done with the metal ones,
you still need to wear retainers,
your teeth,
we'll go back.
It's like muscle memory,
your teeth.
We'll go back easily.
So he got to keep wearing a,
Richard got veneers,
my teeth,
my teeth were really fucked up.
I had some shitty ass teeth.
Would you care to Joe?
Barely want to get him.
I don't know if my bottom ones are
like a fucking city skyline man.
I know a girl got him and she was saying
she's an actress and she was saying it
was really freaky when they
were sawn or teeth down.
Like she got to look at them
before they put the caps on.
He's like,
what have you done to
my [inaudible] back now?
Put those caps on
herbs.
I'm showing to step my game up.
Man,
you look great on,
you don't need so much coffee.
My teeth looked like corn nuts.
Here's the problem.
Your teeth,
there's,
there is a problem in trying
too hard a problem with veneers,
like how much are you trying to teach?
You're trying too hard.
That's not good.
That's just watch that snatching.
Yeah.
Let's watch that.
The vato son
so far,
Jujitsu,
kicking ass when Bella tours.
What is designed for
tonight is Jujitsu shifts.
You know strain partners?
A Justin wren.
Yeah.
They're boys.
They're close.
Justin went down there to
a tight up his game and he,
he hit some submissions now he hit
an arm triangle in one of his fights.
He's the one that's always been his thing.
I'm trying.
It's always been Justin's thing.
He's in Africa.
I know we climbed the tallest mountain.
Look at the swim saving
kids while I'm gone.
Belly down that arm.
It's perfect.
It's that wrist locks out.
Leg over.
Boom.
Supernet hips exchange.
We could have went over that course.
We will want to shut it woulda,
Shoulda,
coulda.
But we have run this plenty of room.
We'll set up another
camera or you know what
testing would be?
Probably because it's
Jujitsu and you need it.
You need to get oh angles.
Two guys do the techniques
and the third guy coaches,
coaches it up.
It follows with that row like a uh,
a remote camera counts here
when I can any of that done,
he's just going to be
fucking messing around.
Shit.
What if I do got a blue belt,
right?
Do this.
Carol does a blue belt and
he wrestled in high school.
Right?
Does he have a blue belt?
I don't think so.
From hands off.
That's what he says.
You wouldn't lie about a blue belt.
We'd have to ask Enzo.
Got It.
He got up.
I remember a long time ago.
He told me that.
Yeah.
I believe he's a blue belt.
I've seen him roll.
We used to do a Carlson Gracie's together.
I've seen him around at first.
Met Him.
No,
he's definitely both white.
I've seen them row.
Does those little sketches he does
on Instagram with the two phones,
iPad beside his head?
No.
And uh,
that other comedian Delea oh yeah,
those guys are fucking hilarious.
We're deleting,
that's his name,
right?
Yeah.
That guy is basically uh,
acting like Brian Callan and Brian.
You know,
he's like super confident.
Like they did that one bit.
I think this,
yeah,
I've seen this one is a good one.
Crystal isn't Denver at this is the video.
He send me other both endeavor right now.
Hi.
Maybe my main man,
my baby.
And My,
a question for you.
I know you're in Denver.
Well,
the answer is no.
I mean,
Denver,
I'm downtown.
How much shitty folk
phones are like you're a,
I'm so loud.
You're doing shows that he
knows that I'm doing shirt.
If there's anything I can do to
help you out to sell some tickets.
I'm doing a show.
Two shows.
Okay.
This
is neck,
teen hundreds,
so that's more of a fleet.
Nuclear,
Cobra,
Cobra.
I'll punch your cobras face if you
just are flat and your nose and I'm
going to want to have this coat.
I'm going to turn you into a call,
but you don't have a face.
That's fine as a cobra,
that's what's going to happen.
I'll flattens Cobra face.
I'll turn it
deleted.
Kellen,
that has a hilarious Instagram.
Callen show got picked up.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Already on a show.
He is.
He was the coach on Goldberg,
but he's got his own show.
He has his own spinoff.
He's The star is still the coach.
Yeah.
The premise is like better call Saul,
Huh?
Yeah.
That's awesome man.
Big Time.
Super happy for him.
Who,
what is what's happening here?
What fight is next?
Main event.
Oh,
isn't a hobby.
Yeah.
I mean the man is this.
The right now should be,
oh shit.
I kind of went,
well,
it's been also first round submissions.
Ha failed the hour and a half more.
There's a manual Sanchez
verse Sam Sicilian.
How does the catch,
because they figured man quick.
This is a good card.
Like we're entertained.
It's a bunch of Mitch mismatches
little sure a little bit,
but it's,
it's good miss.
It's good.
Entertaining matchmaking.
Jujitsu.
This is a seminar dealing.
Dennis said,
this is a seminar.
I saw terrible video of this Jujitsu guy
trying to take down this guy with a gun
and the guy shot him and then got off
of him and shot him twice in the head at
close range.
I was like,
why were you watching that?
Exactly.
Why was I watched it now if
you seen that crazy video,
the crazy crazy one,
which was a crazy,
crazy,
crazy or crazy,
crazy town cartel killing of a car.
I can't watch you do watch that on video.
I mean they,
they record on their phone.
They basically slice the
skin off on a dead person.
There's already a dead person there.
Okay.
The cop and the slices skin all the way.
They scan them alive,
pull out his heart,
cut his heart out,
show it to him,
show it to the camera and worn any,
but it's fucking dark.
It would really,
it's ruined my night.
I'm not interested.
It's the darkest thing I've ever seen it.
The only thing worse would be watching
that happen to a baby or you went super.
That's it.
Yeah.
Let's change the site.
Can't watch that stuff.
It's floating around in the crazy to know
that that's happening somewhere in the
world.
Right.
You know,
two hours away.
Yeah.
It's right there on the
border of California and
texting because of organized
crime and that organized crime is they've,
they're surviving and thriving because
drugs are illegal and they got everyone
paid off.
Have you seen that
documentary cartel land?
Yes.
Jesus.
Christ's best part of that.
That one guy was like,
cannot.
He's going against
the cartel then gets his dick
sucked by his mistress and he goes,
boy,
ain't no boy.
You know?
You know it's funny.
Is it halfway during
through that documentary?
It looks like everyone
being armed as the solution.
So halfway through the documentary,
I'm already texted people called Shit,
you gotta watch this.
Look what happens when
everyone has machine guns.
But then it uh,
it,
it slowly go south.
Have you seen it Joe?
No.
Like the main star.
I haven't seen it.
No.
The main star of it.
He's like fighting back against the cartel
and he's married and he forgets he's
miked up and sees his
mistress and there's subutex.
He's getting his Dick Second.
You see the subjects?
Bueno.
Boy.
Everyone good.
Let's do it.
Yeah,
that's hilarious.
Hero.
And he had a lot of groupies
and he took and you know,
he forgot.
He forgot they were filming.
It was Mike and he had a lot
of group laid the law down.
Sorry.
Jump on them.
I need to see that.
I was telling you about,
uh,
American made the seals movie with Tom
Cruise and other bad ass Tom cruise
movie.
Oh yeah.
See he's on the airplanes.
He was just jumping around.
Yeah,
do.
It's good.
It's really good on me.
It's a good me.
They look,
I know a lot of the Barry seal
story and they covered a lot of,
you can only cover so much
of it in a 90 minute movie.
But yeah,
look,
I mean they did not pull any punches.
They made look like Bill
Clinton got him off.
Bill Clinton called the prosecutor.
They caught him with millions of
dollars and cocaine and money.
Phone call.
Nope.
They have her on the
phone with Bill Clinton.
Bill Clinton,
who like,
he's telling her I'm going to walk.
Whether or not he said that,
I don't know cause he's dead.
No one knows.
Right.
And he's telling her it was,
trust me,
I'm going to walk right out of here.
And they're all laughing and she's like,
you're not going to walk anyway.
And they're like,
Mrs Prosecutor,
Bill Clinton's on the phone
and it's governor Clinton.
Yes.
Yeah.
And you see her go,
you see her,
just get pissed off.
The next thing you know,
they're uncuffing him and he's leaving.
So they're letting you
know that Bill Clinton.
And if they,
if the only way you could put that
in a movie is there has to be truth,
right?
Some truth to him,
they're like,
there's gotta be some sort of a
documented record of him making that call.
Right.
He made that call.
He had to have made that call.
You couldn't switch defamation,
which of course Clinton
and he is the governor.
So there's probably a
record of him saying,
let that guy go.
And so the reason they think
is because in the film,
this is what they're saying is that he
was tied in with the CIA and somehow or
another through the CIA using him for
reconnaissance photos and stuff like that.
And they eventually got hooked up these
drug dealers and started selling drugs.
The CIA was in on it and
they were allowing him to do
it and he was getting them
photographs and Intel from all
these different drug places.
And in return they were letting him do
whatever he did and taking a piece of it
problems,
which you mentioned Mena Arkansas.
Yeah,
yeah.
They mentioned all the,
all the,
I mean that's where Bill Clinton
was the governor of nature.
The only found out about all
this stuff cause two kids were,
they were murdered and they told the
parents that the kids had gotten high and
fell asleep on the train tracks.
But the parents did an independent
autopsy and found stab wounds in the kids.
So like,
oh Jesus,
what the fuck happened here?
And then slowly but surely
the whole thing unravels.
They witnessed a drug drop.
Yeah.
And uh,
well they couldn't have any witnesses,
dude.
They made me like it
was lit case who killed,
go to youtube and just punch in a CIA,
Mena,
Arkansas,
cocaine blow and you get the host.
It's a sitter.
So he kills those.
It could be a two kids.
We don't know.
We don't know somebody who was in our,
assume the cin.
The kids must have seen the drugs be
dropped and whoever was selling the drugs,
moving the drugs,
they just decided to kill these kids
cause they couldn't take a chance.
The kids keeping their mouth shut.
So they killed them.
And apparently that was just one thing.
Now in the movie,
the way they haven't made up is like that.
That was just one thing that's sort
of straw that broke the camel's back.
They don't even have that.
And I don't even remember if
they had that in the movie.
The kids,
did they have that in the movie?
The murder?
They didn't have the murder of the kids.
No they didn't.
But what they did have
is these people were,
I mean everybody was rich.
There were all coming in and
buying things and everyone's like,
where the fuck is all
this money coming from?
Who was rich?
The people that we're working with,
Barry seal's like his brother-in-law,
like his wife's brother apparently.
I don't know if that was a real person,
but in the,
in the movie he's,
he's balling out of control and he's a,
he's got some fucking ridiculous souped
up car and he's got money coming out of
his pockets and he stuffed in his
pocket and he gets caught by a cop.
You know,
and I dunno if that happened in real life,
but in the movie they made it
seem like everybody was just,
there was so much money flowing around,
it didn't make any sense.
They were burying it in his backyard.
They,
when they busted him,
it was like in the movie.
Now again,
I don't know if this was real because
you know what fucked me up man.
That Mark Schultz movie [inaudible] yes,
because I know Mark Schultz fought one
time in the UFC because I watched it.
He fought big daddy Goodrich.
He took big daddy Goodrich down and beat
the shit out and they didn't use good.
No,
not all.
I'm saying.
Dot.
Pick daddy and then movies.
Some random guys fighting a white
guy also the also Schultes hadn't,
there's no gay relationship there.
That's the other one.
He's like,
look man,
the bleached his hair and made him look
like he was and I can't coach culture
like that was weird man.
Weird man.
That Hollywood Shit Schulz told me
that that movie is full of Shit.
Well,
it's,
it's a super set of a shit because he
doesn't fight Gary Goodrich at the end.
Why would you change history?
Like this is what we're
talking about in the soup.
No fucking way.
Check cause I can't trust anything.
I can't trust anything in a movie
like Hollywood doesn't know.
Find me.
The movie was great.
Steve Carell's could ask
[inaudible] amazing as a nose on.
He's amazing.
But I know what really happened.
I know that he fought big daddy Goodrich.
Why isn't he fighting big Daddy
Gorge in your fucking movie?
We'll over the next it.
You can't overlook that she fought once.
It's a part of the move.
I hear you man.
It's,
it's a very,
it's really easy.
Just get a black guy.
So what?
Sign off on his likeness
or it doesn't have to,
he doesn't have to its history.
There's a reality to it.
You don't have to have him say his name.
You show big daddy
Goodrich across from them.
You show him,
you know you have mark Scholz,
you'd just cut into it right when they're
introducing and have a black and then
have the guy and you know
have them where the Geeky,
just like big daddy Goodrich had a key on.
It's kind of navigate through.
This is stupid.
You can't change history.
This is a real historical moment.
It was a moment when one of the best
wrestlers on the fucking planet earth,
a legit,
super high level Olympian fought in the
UFC and he only fought once and you got
to see how easy he took an elite MMA
fighter down and just dominated him.
That was an important
historical moment in MMA.
That's right.
Range.
They miss the changing who
breaks Jackie Robinson's record,
a Babe Ruth's record or or Mickey Mantle.
You changing his,
you could never do that with
baseball and nobody would let you.
You don't think that because those are
major sports in a lot of people would
know that with MMA there's like,
yeah,
whatever man.
They might have done that,
but that makes me not trust
everything else in the movie.
Because if you did that
with a very important point,
let's a very important point,
because people to go,
which is a legend that the Paul Herrera
knockout and Paul Herrera had him like a
fireman's carry and he hit him with all
those LDLs and that's probably the most
brutal Kale and so history kind of them.
It's certainly,
certainly one of them.
I mean that was a terrifying,
terrifying Kao.
How easy is that for them to fix too?
If you just put some sort of reference
to Gary Goodrich to big daddy Goodrich,
he had kicked on fry,
remember that he's a monster.
Kicked him and Kayo them.
You know,
big daddy Goodrich's an important
historical figure in MMA.
You can't just change the name of the guy.
Mark Schultz fights can movie though.
I lost,
I lost faith in a,
based on a true story movies
when the Dragon came out,
the Bruce Bruce Lee movie,
but Jason Scotland,
he did a,
he was,
he played Bruce Lee and I love
so much bullshit in there.
Oh my God.
I love filled with
bullshit it in the movie,
in the movie,
he had a real fight at
the long beach arena.
He was just,
in reality,
he was just doing demonstrations,
but in the movie they had him.
He didn't have a real fight though.
He didn't have a real fight there.
And then a movie it during the fight,
his opponent,
bro,
like broke his back with a
sidekick in the movie he was in.
The hospital's heartbreaking in reality.
Fucked his backup.
Lifting,
lifting weights.
He was lifting weights
is back in that fight.
No,
he never had to redeem
himself mostly to death.
But he never had a professional fight.
Ever,
ever.
Right.
Never.
Not One fight.
No.
I don't think he ever competed.
I don't think he had an amateur
fight.
He fought like he had on the streets,
on the streets,
and he fought in the YMC Aa for the
right to teach Non-asians Kung Fu in San
Francisco.
That'd be a flower was a thing.
Yeah.
That he had real fights,
that he was a real fighter,
but he didn't have a
real professional fight.
He didn't have anything like that.
He broke his back lifting weights.
Not in a professional fights.
Was He lifted?
When I saw that,
I thought okay,
I can't trust any Hollywood movies now
based on a true story and gains because
it's a little bit,
they got,
they got a paint a narrative a little bit.
No,
no.
Well no you can't.
No,
no,
no.
Now it's,
now it's inspired by true events.
Files.
Yeah,
I dig that Shit.
Can't entertain stuff.
You can't add stuff.
You can't add a gay relationship.
You can't add a karate kick to the back.
That fucks you up.
Puts in the hospital.
You can't add that.
Oh in,
in the,
in reality he had to fight,
uh,
if he,
if he beat this guy out of y Ymca,
he had the right to teach non agents
cause that was an issue back then.
It was the 60s.
Yeah.
They're like why are you
teaching in Americans are shit.
And he's like,
I'll teach anybody who the fuck I want.
So he had to fight and went to
wine at a YMCAs in the movie.
In the movie.
It was in an underground cavern with like
elders and these little spots and the
scratchy did these,
did he scratch his chest and then the
guy put this back up again as he kicks
him?
Yes,
but it's like it was in
a weird like Illuminati.
I love that part though.
I hate when they do that.
Yeah,
it was all bullshit.
It was a great room.
Can't do that about a
real watch of documentary.
You fuck.
That's like when Abraham
Lincoln fought the vampires.
It was obvious it wasn't
really that good ass movie.
That's a good movie though.
What if that was real?
Hey,
we don't know.
Maybe he killed them all and that's
why we could sleep good at night.
That movie is so underrated.
We do know a lot of people out
there are drinking baby blood.
Maybe after a while you turn in like to
into like little like a vampire or kind
of person.
You imagine if vampires or something.
You really had to worry about.
Oh my God.
Might be out there.
We're so funny.
Imagine if there was dudes out there
sucking people's blood and a bunch of
people found with like the,
their juggler veins
tapped into by those two,
two prongs to,
isn't it weird that it's kind of romantic
like chicks think pedantics things
that you buy at a girl's new blood,
but you could.
Why Two?
Because it's the guy loves you so much.
You're willing,
you love him so much.
You willing to be the undead and you'll
go for attorney like the best one ever
by far.
Twilight Gary Oldman and Wynona Ryder,
Bram Stoker's Dracula.
Fuck shit is so Ben tasks.
I made a music video interview with the
vampire is fucking good to very good,
but it's a different
hat and put top girls.
Yeah,
Dude.
Tom Cruise killed it.
And that two killed in that to look
good in that with that little girl.
That little girl was fucked up.
What's
that little girl's,
uh,
Kristen Dunst.
Yes.
She's amazing.
She's amazing in that movie.
She's fucking fantastic and she's like
10 and she's killing it as a little bit
back a little bit to them was
terrifying too because you believe it.
I know.
And she would like dress those people
up after they were dead and people were
like,
what the fuck you killed them.
And even top crews like you gotta
chill out cause she was killing it.
Couldn't help but she could kill him.
See that now?
Fuck yeah.
I want to smell other large pizza.
I'd watch that.
She might've been the
scariest vampire ever.
That little girl,
she's up there.
Right?
Cause she's so fucking cute and so vicious
because she was like 300 years old,
but she was 10.
You know who's not a bad vampire is
calling Farrell in a neither living dead.
Not Bad at all.
Not Bad.
It's not night of the living dead.
It's um,
I know what you're talking about.
It's the newest one.
The yeah,
the kid who died,
what is it called?
The fuck is it called?
It's not night.
And I live in dead.
I don't think so.
No,
it's like from dusk till dawn.
Now that was good.
Do Friday night.
That's it.
Fright night.
Um,
dusk till dawn.
Good.
[inaudible] our movies have there been,
I watch them all.
I really want to push those things.
I love them.
Jesus Christ.
Why light ones the most with them?
They could live in the Seattle area
because it never was sunny shit.
They had the makeup on fucking,
they don't burn when the sun hits
them and that was an empire movie,
right?
Blades a fucking good.
That's a good no call
pharaoh was a beast in that.
That's a good movie or a vampire movie.
Movies and space.
Louise.
No,
no,
no.
I think,
I think there are no,
no star wars aliens.
Star track.
You can just keep going on event
horizon been going on and on.
Green home,
boy.
Hey,
if you guys seen lost in space on Netflix,
if you heard anything about it.
No.
And he didn't hear anything about that.
Jamie Lawson space
supposed to be any good.
I look good.
I didn't hear good reviews so,
oh,
I know they did it.
They got a new show they're doing with
that chick from Battlestar Galactica.
Katie,
how do you see her name's sack off?
She's bad ass nasty.
Ever see Battlestar Galactica.
The PSI five version wasn't Battlestar
Galactica with old school John Travolta,
the worst movie of all time.
No,
no.
Got Battlefield Earth.
There you go.
Yeah,
you're,
you're fucking,
Trump gave NASA a whole
shit load of money,
like $19 billion and said,
okay,
here's the money,
but we're going to fucking know.
Let's go to the moon.
So they,
they started a campaign to go to the
moon and they just canceled the mission.
Why?
Oh No,
no,
no.
They didn't cancel the mission.
They canceled the Moon Rover.
You canceled it.
They canceled the,
the construction of the moon
and everybody's confused.
They don't know how they did that because
this is like the last moon rover that
they,
unless they have some new top secret
moon rover that they don't want to let
anybody know about it.
Maybe they found some new cool shit.
Maybe.
Probably.
Yeah.
Maybe they can't go.
Well actually,
if we really did go in and like,
okay,
give us the money.
Let's figure it out.
Okay,
we'll figure it out.
We got 19 billion.
If we really didn't find out,
nobody else is working on it.
Putting a the rover on the moon,
but,
and the,
and the NASA wasn't
either until Trump said,
here's the money,
let's go to the fucking moon.
And then we're going to Mars.
She matched.
If Trump goes on TV and says
there's a lot of things talk about,
one of them is,
it's terrible tragedy.
We've never been to the moon.
Ladies and gentlemen.
That's some shit he would do.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
He doesn't know.
How do you know he doesn't let him know
he's too busy with us friends with Alex
Jones.
He's a really talked that
much cause you can't,
they can't.
Everywhere they go,
the wearing wires,
everyone's wearing a wire.
Their phones are being tapped.
Q a nine is Qa and I've heard about that.
It's crazy shit.
What is it?
Qa non is someone in the
Trump administration,
but people think it's someone
in intelligence in the
military who's dropping all
these clues on four Chan and eight Chan.
So the whole thing is,
is it real?
Is it disinformation?
If someone playing a trick,
but it's he,
he legally can't say what's
going on behind the scenes.
Nothing leg lock.
Look at this.
He legally can't say he's getting
it because it's against the law.
So he,
he's dropping all these clues and it's a,
it's someone named Q Anan and it's been
going on for about three months and
there's all these people
in the underground.
Uh,
basically he's saying trust the president.
It's going to take a while to take down
all these corrupt people at the top of
the FBI and the Department
of Justice and all the shit.
We're going to take them down one by one.
So He's been dropping all these
clues on how they're going to do it.
It's pretty interesting.
You listen to it every day
has drops every day and it's,
it's like,
uh,
it gets addicting,
but you don't know if it's real or not.
Like is it,
is it disinformation?
It's called Q Anan and Pete,
he makes drops every day and leaves all
these clues of what's going on behind
the scenes.
No one can trace back to find out
who he is or anything like that.
No,
I think on four Chan or eight Chan,
isn't it?
Like,
if you can,
you can hackers know
how to drop information,
information without being tracked,
right?
For sure.
Right?
Is that,
that's what's going on and on.
I know you have,
right?
Yeah.
There's a bunch of posts about it,
but again,
who knows if it's real or not,
but the people that,
I mean,
there's people who who,
uh,
there's a guy named Jerome
Corsi who works for Alex Jones,
who that's his job is to analyze what's
all of these clues of what's going on,
what Trump is doing behind the scenes,
because he's got the media all the time,
media,
Hollywood,
FBI,
and what they're finding out is they're
finding text messages and emails going
back and forth,
uh,
between key people,
running the government
colluding to destroy Trump.
That's what's going on.
So for sure it's a crazy shun him around.
No,
none of those people that have been
in politics but politics forever.
They didn't think he was going to win.
So they did all this shit
thinking Hillary was gonna win,
but now that he won,
they're going back and looking at all
the text messages from all of these super
powerful people.
People are are are resigning.
It's crazy shit going on
and most people don't know.
It's like game of Thrones for real.
You're not game of Thrones has like 50
characters and it would take you about a
month to to to catch up on what's going
on and it's just so much going on.
That's what's going on.
There's a game of Thrones going on right
now but the media is only going to tell
you their side and then Qa non is dropping
the behind the scenes clues but it's
pretty fascinating.
Arm Triangle here.
There's another seminar.
This is 100% it's all a hundred percent
it's over a hundred percent the camera,
oh go back to the camera.
He's talking to it.
You should jump to full guard
and she jumped the full guard.
Why do you think this is definitely done?
It's so deep in,
the guy's not doing
anything with his left hand.
While he wasn't,
if he just jumps down,
there you go.
Okay,
it's over now.
It's no way.
No Way.
He's going to
four five for submission,
arm triangle in full guard.
His bet.
And how about the arm triangle from
standing position drags him to the ground
stage.
Is it?
Yeah,
that was sick.
That happens every now and then.
You see it every now and then when
you gotta you gotta you gotta,
you gotta be tapping people so
much with your arm triangle.
You have so much faith in it and it's
gotta be a Goto to take a chance like
that.
If it's not your go to.
That's why you don't really see it
because there's not that many fighters
overall in MMA that are known
for amazing harm triangles.
It's kind of popular.
It is probably,
you know,
I would say 25% of MMA fighters
have high level arm triangles.
I would say maybe that's a little high,
but you know about 2020 5% well,
what he did there that was
special was get sideways.
He was doing like a rear
naked choke from the side.
Is that a Brazilian or a Mexican?
What is his name?
Jamie
fought Samsung.
The Brazil flag on the short.
This is dope.
Look how it clamps has shit down.
Very interesting.
Cause he look out tidy gets hit man.
He gets it super tight.
Will Sanchez Manual Sanchez
Mexicans.
They got hard.
Dude.
This is phenomenal.
Do you know who needs to make it?
Come back to full guard.
Look at this.
See what he's doing with his left hand.
He's not really protecting anything.
So that shows me that uh,
he kind of doesn't know
how to get out of it.
Wow.
Super Snuggie that's amazing.
The Mexican that we need to come back.
Does Yoyo Rodriguez.
Oh,
he was offered Yair
Rodriguez that beat correct.
Magwell bed shower actually
came into my gym last week.
A couple days.
He's a did.
Yup.
She came in with Kelvin.
They've been hanging out all,
he's phenomenal.
Phenomenal.
You don't want to see him versus IB.
No.
Why not?
Hold hold.
Don't want someone to lose
the only amazing fight.
Yeah,
you're just fought Frankie Edgar.
Well his last fight with frank get lost.
Right.
Got dismantled.
So you got to toss him fucking beat.
Who could probably beat
the top five right now.
So for a kid,
why not?
Who wouldn't want to see that?
The heart we do.
But if you're,
if you care about,
yeah,
here the heart chords knows I beat,
but he's not a huge name.
So for a year it's a huge risk.
So you can stop,
get back in the [inaudible].
I think you beat them.
It's a tough fucking fight for a man.
I have to Frankie Edgar,
right?
True.
Do you want to buy different fight?
I'd like to see it because a year and my
opinion has the most dynamic standup in
all of MMA cause he
throws so much crazy shit.
He's done the wild shit.
I love it.
Listen man.
So does that beat,
that's why I want to see it.
I want to see it.
It looked like a beats rest
like a Jackie Chan fight.
Sabina is a,
he's got a bunch of like really
solid fundamental movements.
Like when he lands,
like he'll throw something
and even if he liked he's off.
He'll shuffle and adjust and
always be in perfect position.
Like he's really good at like throwing
kicks and throwing punches or elbows or
knees.
Anything he does,
he's,
he hits you and then boom,
he's in prep.
Doesn't have any holes.
Yeah,
he didn't,
he never say him stumble or look weird.
He's never like off balance
or the same team as could be.
No.
Awesome.
Mark Henry Guy,
he's Mark Henry Guy,
New Jersey mark.
Cause they're talking about them.
They're kind of fair friends.
They're all from Dagestan place.
Maybe they trained,
maybe they came up together in the
same club because I see this pretty big
Khabib.
Khabib is always reach.
We treating,
we tweeting,
retreating,
retreating from the motherland.
But zombied is a very different game.
I mean he's not a wrestler per se.
He's,
he's got really good Jujitsu.
He's got very good,
he's good at everything.
So if your guy here
and you're a young kid,
you just get your ass whooped
by Frank Jase taking a year off.
He's trying to figure things
out and you're going to fight.
Is that beat?
Who could I think could hang
with the top five right now.
You want to find right
now and he's ranked what?
Maybe 14th.
13th.
Um,
she gonna find them.
We'll let him fight when he's like five,
three,
two eight when he was the champ.
Not now.
I know.
Is that beats people
want to check the site.
I don't know if they
made that fact though.
I don't know cause I know,
I know.
Yeah.
Buyer's agent.
Congrats on a great winds up beat.
It'd be an honor to fight you one day.
We'll have to meet each other in the top
10 which I know you'll make quickly my
next fight coming up.
So stay tuned.
I know.
Jaegers agent really well and they're not,
there's no way they take that fight.
That's what it is.
You think they made a conscious decision
now's not the right time to find them.
Wait till his top 10 and I agree
with you on the top 10 or Heidi.
Right.
In my opinion and my opinion.
Yeah,
I watched him against Bochniac and again,
you know Boq Nats,
super tough guy.
Kyle Bachman Magomed Sharapov fla.
It's not even happening for me.
Damn.
I'm a been three years ago.
I stumbled through ruined a
couple of times at the weigh ins.
I stumbled through it.
Did you have to track this?
Will you read it?
Like if I read it like I,
I've,
I've watched him fight but when I
watched him fight it says this is a beat,
whatever the fuck his last
name is [inaudible] and then,
but it wasn't until I have to call it,
I got to remember here it like if I
hear you say it like multiple times,
then I pick it up
mega med.
Sure.
Paul Magomed Chicago Edge.
That's not that hard.
But they want you to just,
is that beat because like for American
fans like that's a hard sell when Norma
got Madoff is hard but everybody calls
him could be in for the most part.
Yeah.
Does that beat is super high level man.
I was so impressed with his striking
the way many of the broken arm or broken
fist into the fight entered the fight
with her hitting the pads I got mucked up
is Mark Henry told me he's
the most talented guy he's
ever seen come through as
Jim Rez Barboza.
Frankie Edgar says the beat
by far the most talented guy.
That's how bad is it?
Credible fight with Barboza.
Oo dammit.
He's a beast.
Kevin Leila.
Kevin.
See I think Kevin Lee
Kobi was a great fight.
Great Fun.
Because I think at two down,
see,
I think Kevin Lee does things better.
Some things better than
Khabib does and could be,
does some things better than Kevin,
but I think Kevin's better.
The more important things.
It's hard to tell who does what better.
It really is because they're
both so good at everything.
Not only comes to quick
strike showing him no,
no.
Kevin.
Kevin,
we have by a long shot.
Yeah,
he's good.
Yeah.
Can bebes good.
Kevin.
Kevin to stretch.
It'd be better standing up there.
The real question is going to be in the
wrestling because Khabib's it's number
one.
Goal's not stand up and have
a kickboxing match with you.
It's no one goes to mall year
and whoever gets the take down,
it all comes down to how good
the guy on the bottom is.
Office cat.
Kevin's a better cop.
Kevin's a better grappler.
He's better at finishing from the back.
Correct?
I can't say.
And I get his mouth and his past and
his finished his passing in that fight,
the passing and the first row.
First of all,
I took Barboza down quicker
than could be did it could beep,
struggled.
Barboza shook him off a couple of times,
but cubby breaks everybody.
Everybody that grapples with them,
you find out,
you know,
Kevin has a higher takedown success.
Right?
But Khabib,
even against guys that are really good,
like dos Anjos,
he mauls those fuckers.
He knows people.
No,
it's a great fighter.
Great.
Like Kevin,
he's getting,
he's new to the 25 years old.
So in 25 he's smart.
It's,
who knows who can take
Kevin Lee as smart as fuck.
John and Kevin.
Kevin Lee could beep to me is the most
interesting fight beside as soon as he
gets out.
Tony itself get about dre.
He's out for a little bit and
that's why Tony Tony could be about,
I'd love to see that but I go see Tony,
Nate Diaz.
But however with Tony being hurt so I
don't put them in the discussion right
now.
Kevin Lee Khabib's the fights fair,
that surgery that that stitches the side,
the size of the fucking wound ever seen
anything like that in my life was like a
motorcycle accident was whole
LCL came off that poor dude.
I've never seen anybody with horrible
or horrific like surgical wound on their
knee.
That's hard.
That's like some 1980 shit.
Like when they used to have to open you
up and like a suitcase and check around
and replace Shit and he's
not a guy I'm worried about.
You know some guys when they get
an injury I'm like Oh fuck the,
I'm not worried about
Tony for some reason.
Look at that though dude.
Do you know how big that is?
That's a giant ass wound that
looks like a 12 inch wound,
had to reattach the whole thing.
That's a rare knee operation right there.
The fact that that happened while he was
just walking and tripped is so fucking
crazy that a guy with his kind of balance,
he must've been exhausted.
That's the only thing that makes sense.
He must've been just run ragged doing all
these interviews and then like peaking
during training.
Just a freak accident way.
Yeah.
I'm just making things up.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
Fuck,
but it's such a bummer.
Oh,
we should [inaudible] I've
talked about this before.
We should talk about it again.
He was not wearing sunglasses.
That was something he misspoke.
He said he was wearing prescription
sunglasses to Ariel Helwani.
Is that what he said?
It was a mistake.
So everybody's repeating this,
including me and Dana and
all these other people.
We thought he was wearing sunglasses
inside like he does when he does so stare
downs.
It's not what was going on.
Even if he was,
I don't think regular
glasses and sunglasses.
It had nothing to do with it.
He just tripped.
I don't care what some
people were mocking him.
Oh really?
You know,
especially when the guy's like half
the door and most important part of his
career thought anyway.
I know he was going to fight anyway.
Crazy.
In a good way.
He was.
He was,
he didn't care.
You guys remember pride when Sakuraba
would literally wrap his legs up like a
mummy.
That's what Tony was going to get.
The doctors wouldn't let him.
So he went to two
different documents can be,
it's not fine for a
while because of Ramadan.
Right?
I don't know.
He can't fight to Ramadan.
He's out for a few months
because of his religion.
Yeah.
So then you do what?
Eddie Alvarez,
who fought through Ramadan,
went through his train
clamp through Ramadan,
is a below Muhammad.
He figured out a way to do it and the way
to do it is to train it til nighttime.
Make sure he eats first and
then trains at nighttime.
But he did it.
I thought,
well,
no,
he did it.
He did.
And he fought.
Well,
he just adjusted his,
did he try to camp?
I forget.
I don't remember who we follow.
I'm saying at a championship level,
I would hold off too
if I'm could be right.
I see what you're saying.
But you can do it.
But I remember he fought a good guy.
I don't remember who
it was was interesting.
Yeah.
He figured out his schedule
where he could pull it off.
He can't be the best way to go about it.
The best way to go.
It was a bad ass do it.
If it wasn't for your religion,
there's no way I'd do it.
Just be for performance.
There's no way you would do it,
but you could do it.
It could be done because you
just got to wait until dark.
Right.
If I'm compete though,
I just saw on down,
it's not that hard.
It's not ideal.
Well,
it's fascinating and it's ideal.
Apparently these days it's the best thing.
No,
but it,
but it's not the way,
first of all,
if you're going to do it,
you wouldn't do it like that.
Like he wouldn't do it during the
dude like that and you you wouldn't,
you would do it where you stop eating
and like five in the afternoon and then
you would go off if you
want to have like a long,
some people argue that's good.
Who argues that sound good?
Well just from your,
from our human genetics that
you can be hungry at night.
Right,
so you don't get as good a sleep.
Yeah,
but it depends on what
kind of foods are reading.
That's a big part of what it is.
If you're eating a lot
of refined carbohydrates,
you're going to get really
hungry at night for sure.
And you're going to want to eat again.
But if you're on more of a fat based Diet,
you could pull that off for sure.
100% a hundred non stop man.
Yeah,
you could pull it off for sure.
The real question is,
is that the best thing to do for physical
performance and it's most likely not
say no.
I don't think so.
We had Zack bitter in here the other day.
He's a he,
he all ready for this record.
This motherfucker ran a hundred
miles in 11 hours and 40 minutes.
He was averaging a seven minute
mile shit for almost 12 hours.
He weighs four pounds.
Yeah,
Ebay's a buck 40.
He's,
but he's a very thin guy.
He's on a fat based Diet.
He's on a Keto Diet essentially.
But when he goes to race he
takes a lot of carbohydrates,
sugars and everything.
No white guy.
Super Smart.
Kevin.
White Dude.
Really Nice Guy.
Um,
but imagine that shit happened strong.
Your fucking mind has to be strong.
Your mind has to be to run
11 hours and 40 minutes.
Is that a word?
A minute.
Yup.
That's it.
Or the U s record us,
record us American record who
holds the record so he probably,
Mexicans can run marathons.
We don't play football or basketball,
but shit,
she didn't run for a long ass time and
though the mountains of Mexico City,
Him and well that's what part of that um,
book born to run that
she loves us mountain.
Yeah.
Those guys who ran like
basically barefoot.
Yeah.
There's some boys in a New Mexico too.
They're like the number
one cross country team.
All the Mexicans there
oil,
the white kids.
Mexicans are really known for Cardio.
It's very interesting.
Heart,
heart and cardiac hook to look at that.
Look at the boxers.
Look at the MMA fighters.
MMA fighters,
boxers.
Yup.
No one for cardio.
How about Julio?
Cesar Chavez.
Ah,
fucker.
Just was overwhelming.
He never stopped coming at you.
He was,
he was so beautiful when
he was in his prime.
When he would throw
combinations like to the body,
to the head,
upper cuts stepped to the side,
right hand,
left hook,
right hand to the body.
He was just nonstop.
His volume was so impressive in his
placement just to fucking amazing.
Hey,
what's going on here?
It's so fast to just toss.
Fatal is not ready.
The record is held by a
25 year old Russian ship.
Powerful EPO.
11 1128 I can't trust
anything after ICARUS.
You like,
wait,
what?
I hit rush and I assume
you can't trust them.
I mean,
isn't all countries different
show shirt for sure.
A hundred percent hundred percent
they just got busted once.
You watched ICARUS though.
Yeah,
I saw it.
Well,
even when Zach was
talking about the testing,
when Zach was talking to me
about testing for these things,
he was,
he was kind of led on that.
One of the things that's different is the
culture of the guys that run a hundred
miles.
Like it's not in the culture,
whereas like in the cycling culture,
it's a big part of the culture.
Like everybody does it.
But in the,
the,
that ultra marathon
world is a brain world.
That's a world of like
how much can you take?
Like you can physically do it.
They're not doing
anything crazy physically,
like Usain bolt or someone who
would not get the genetic right.
But they're there.
They're all small though.
Right.
I would love to do them.
Another sound,
another fucking sob.
God Damn Bar.
It's a seminar.
Cash.
Dylan's rash.
High Level Jujitsu.
Tonight's 17.
Nice.
Yes.
Hairlines out to,
um,
what we're just saying.
Well,
we just,
Oh,
I was saying those guys are small though.
Genetically.
They're not like freaks.
I wish I could do it,
but I'm just to gut ambig.
Yeah,
it's a shame.
Well,
you'd have to lose weight for sure.
You'd have to dry yourself out.
Oh,
it's to honor.
Love it that much.
Even when Cam,
when he does like the big ones,
like when he did the Moab to 40 he got
down to sick to one 60 rather once 65 I
think he's a big dude.
Usually weighs about one 85 be mighty.
Got To one 60 you might actually got
right below one 60 but he sowed so
hardcore.
You know how he did it?
He just worked out burn 4,000 calories,
eight,
3000 skus doing that.
He did that.
Something hard to piece your mind.
I wish they would show that again,
but the way he set that arm bar up,
it was he a remember the teepee crossing
your ankles and you extend your legs
instead of leg curl.
When the extended him,
it put everything in a in a right
angle and then he upped it over.
Then he hit or guest tattoo too.
That's in game of Thrones shit.
Do you know what?
I've been watching vikings.
I can't get into Viking.
Dude.
It's a good God damn show.
You got to get four episodes in.
I uh,
no I haven't watched it
gets too complicated.
Now I saw that.
I saw first episode.
I'm like,
shit,
what's going on guys?
Refresh any of the old ones before he
started the new one because it's been a
swell.
The preview is like three minutes long.
They kind of give you a
good background of it.
I never got into
the opening as all the,
uh,
the robots don't tell me anything.
Okay.
Don't tell me how dare
you find out right away.
I'm just waiting for game
of Thrones star alert.
Where are you confused?
Don't get confusing.
And kind of the first
season was very confusing.
Also.
It took a while to fit.
They're saying that what?
Caesar,
they and now three second,
they're saying it's so confusing.
They're losing subscribers.
Like ratings are just fucking,
but how do they know it's one
episode that I just read that Bro,
you know what?
We'll just write shit like that
just to be assholes I think today.
Yeah.
I think there's maybe
the writers confused.
So like everyone's confused.
You talked about it,
so you already talked,
not validated.
You talked about it because it's a
thing that you want to hear and go,
Oh man,
look what's going on over there.
No,
I don't.
Too complicated.
I like West Hall.
I heard the loosened subscribers.
Maybe
if you're going to sell magazines or an
article and you want to appeal to that
mindset that we're just
talking about earlier,
that's what you would,
right.
You're right,
but I'm saying is that last thing
I read was that on Westworld.
I don't watch Westworld.
I'm not sure if people dig it.
He never watched it.
No.
You've got to start from scratch.
I'm telling you it's a good show.
I know people love it,
man.
You can't do it.
I don't know.
You seem like you're never going to do it.
I talking to you right now.
He'd be like,
yeah,
yeah.
Just same way with game of Thrones,
but then you guys talked me into it.
This is my favorite show of all time.
There you go,
telling you,
dude,
get season one of Vikings.
These dudes.
Fuck people up.
It's fun.
It's on history.
Could,
I think it's basically a historical
reenactment of the Viking days based on a
true story.
Yeah.
Ragdar Loft Brook,
who was a real viking like real shit.
If they know that they
wrote down every word,
they listen to me,
man.
They wrote down every word they
said all throughout the day,
his whole life.
So they got it.
They got there by fuck.
You even get the can read Viking.
You know who knows what
the guy said and did,
but it's a really well made show.
It's the acting is fucking amazing.
I think they have five seasons.
What are they trying to do?
They're just trying to
go from town to town.
Dude,
I don't want them to take it.
I don't want to fuck it up,
but it's based on real sieges that
they did when they patent was oil.
Harris history attacked England.
They went and they attacked west six
they killed a fuck load of people.
They showed up on boats and just jumped
out with axes and just start fucking up
villages.
It's,
it's based on that Barrick shit,
but it's really well done,
man.
I,
you know,
I was skeptical.
I never heard anything about
it and someone was saying,
you got to watch Netflix.
Hulu.
No,
I got it on an apple.
It's probably on Netflix.
It's a history channel.
It was a history channel show.
I just subscribed to it on iTunes.
I got a that apple,
what is it?
I home.
What does that shit called?
Apple TV.
Yeah,
I heard frontiers good too.
It's about the fur trading
business with your boy.
The Jason Momoa heard.
It's really good to,
hmm.
Interesting.
I don't watch any of them
Viking,
so I'm hooked.
I'm hooked.
I just finished season three.
Damn your ass.
It's fucking good,
man.
It's a good show.
It's one of those
underrated shows you like.
How do I not know about this one?
I've heard about it.
I'm just not vikings.
They're like,
yeah,
you do like that.
I love that shit.
I watch teen mom does.
Did you guys watch wild,
wild country?
I'm scared.
[inaudible] wild country.
It's a dock you a series.
It's on that guy.
The the sex cult guy,
right?
Yeah.
It's more of a like an Indian dude.
His,
his name is,
um,
he has like three different names,
but his,
his religion was half Buddhists,
half a capitalist.
Like I'm in,
like
I'm in the spirit.
You can be spiritual,
but you want to add luxury too?
Yes.
Yeah,
he could
do both.
I'm in jail son.
And he said,
he says,
I believe in luxury.
I believe we all should live in luxury,
but if you can't live in luxury,
I'm going to live in luxury myself.
Is he a bad guy?
That guy right there.
Oh yeah.
He's super pimped out all these roles.
Make sure built.
So what happens is they
get kicked out of India,
so he has all these rich followers
and they built a city in Oregon,
that coalition in the middle of nowhere.
They built this gigantic
city in Oregon in the 80s.
And all these people from all over
the world ended up moving there.
And the surrounding towns are
just like old white people.
They,
uh,
they go to war and a,
that's what the documentary is about.
It's pretty awesome.
It's an awesome,
what was he having sex
with everyone or what man,
it's not about that.
It's about him starting a new city with
that got tens of thousands of people in
the middle of Oregon and they got all
these old white people out there going,
what the fuck is going on?
So it wasn't about a sex cult.
They,
you know,
they believed in free
sex and all that stuff,
but it wasn't,
doesn't it's the cold leads
just focusing on that,
that it's more about,
they had to find out a culture.
They had the finances to literally
build a high level city in the middle of
nowhere.
And when did this all go down?
In the 80s.
Okay.
I'm going to watch it.
Uh,
I can't watch it this weekend.
It's really good.
It's really good,
man.
You won't regret that one.
Okay.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
The cult leaders always charismatic and
they're always trying to fuck everyone.
Wild.
Did you start a cult?
Why else?
Well,
you just want everybody just listen to,
you know,
and then you want the poster correct.
Come on.
Every time.
Called the personality and the type of
person that would want to have all those
people.
Ladies and gentleman,
we're going to move to Oregon.
We found a spot.
Yes,
exactly.
That's exactly what it was.
Went to white people
from all over the world,
but they were rich.
I know someone whose family
was involved in that.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Get the sake of things about it.
It's interesting to see how it
all comes crashing down though.
That's,
that's the interesting part is like
how does it come crashing down?
Because it's,
it doesn't exist.
I don't know.
Mine's a friend of mines,
ex girlfriend from like 20 plus years ago.
She grew up in that
and that one in Oregon.
She think it's that one.
I'm pretty sure it's that one.
She was afraid I'd have to ask him.
I don't know how I'd bring that up.
Really.
Can't just text him.
Hey Bro,
watching this dog.
Was it your old girlfriends?
Yeah.
Imagine that,
man.
Imagine like you being in one of them
called and like being like 10 years old
and I'm like looking around going,
what is going on?
If,
why is the Maharaja keep fucking my mom?
Like what's happening here?
You're not going to grow up normal.
Yeah.
You can be pretty damaged.
Um,
mom,
what are you doing?
Well,
the sacred one brings to me blessing on
duty at all these rolls Royces in the
middle of eastern Oregon.
Yeah.
He would just why multiple like
endless rolls Royces fallen.
I believe in luxury.
The line is if I can't manage to
make everybody live in luxury,
at least I can manage to
live in luxury myself.
Just for Shit didn't,
um,
didn't fucking r Kelly
get in trouble recently.
They think he's running a call.
He has kind of,
he has to be a sex slave.
So he has won the house.
Kind of what he does is he has,
he has one house where he
stays and he is a next door.
He bought the house.
He's a bunch of flock a bitches in there.
And so the parents of those kids are like,
he's holding them hostage.
There's sex slaves.
These taken away their
confidence when really it's just,
you know,
pimp it.
Yeah.
He's,
he's pimping,
pimping,
pimping r Kelly.
Part of his inner circle resign amid sex.
Pet allegations does this
today and heard about the pets.
It was last week.
This is what we saw Tony about to hope
high profile women have resigned their
roles after new revelations emerged
and a BBC three documentary.
Oh,
that's what we're talking about.
Some girl from a small vil.
Did you hear about that?
Fuck is going on.
What in the fuck?
Like she's trying to recruit
actresses to be in the sex cult.
When did she,
when did she do,
is this from the past?
I don't know that the last few
years from the past a little bit,
but also I think it's just she got up,
she was trying to get Emma Watson
to take join or something like that.
I don't know.
This is just stuff that's
coming on the mainstream medium.
Maybe it's all bullshit.
I Dunno.
Well she's got to prison though.
Yeah.
Why would she do that?
And they would,
they would have,
uh,
they had,
um,
they would have parties.
This,
this,
this thing that she was involved in
at adapt Richard Branson's island.
Look at this.
It says she's accused of being a
leader in a pile for a sorority.
Ask Right?
Young women who were manipulated into
serving as slaves for male masters.
She's facing 15 years to life imprisonment
on the charge of sex trafficking,
conspiracy and conspiracy
to commit forced labor.
Okay.
Now let me ask you this.
If you run into a bunch of girls,
say you're this girl and your
thing is like being in a,
a cult with one master who gets
to fuck all these women whose,
whose to say that you shouldn't
be into that if you're her,
right?
You know,
and now who's to say if she goes and
talks to a bunch of other girls and talks
them into having sex with this guy,
why is that bad?
That's what I'm saying.
We should get what you
want your daughter to do.
It's not what you want your sister to do.
But we all know people that like getting
tied up 100% we know people that like,
like smacking each other and like
being sent shit and like being,
well not really,
maybe slaves,
but whatever.
People like Kinky Shit.
Let's just say that,
right?
They like Kinky Shit.
Why is it that we can decide
that that's too kinky?
Because is she bringing those girls there
and then they're keeping them right?
That's the question.
If that's the case,
of course it says forced labor labor,
right?
If you scroll right,
but if you turn someone into
your slave and you said slave,
you're going to clean my kitchen.
And they're like,
yes,
master.
And it's like part of some
weird kinky shit you do.
And then after they cleaned your
kitchen then then you mouth fuck them.
Yeah.
Like if you just decided
like you have some words,
she have some weird weird like
that and some people like it,
some people like weird shit.
And then there's some people that get
talked into joining a cult and they get
talked into these horrible situations.
They actually do become sex slaves.
So how do you know which is which?
How do you know like which is a consenting
of age adult who really loves being a
part of some super kinky shit.
I know.
Versus someone who's coerced into
joining a sex cult and who is like held
against their will.
Like there's a line there,
right?
Like they seem kind of similar from
the outside but there is a line,
right.
I don't know what the fuck
happened in this situation.
I literally don't know anything.
I do know,
I know what happens.
So she would get these girls and then
the shoot dude get them naked and she
would take pictures and hold
it as a brand somewhere.
Like if they didn't fuck the leader.
Oh,
okay.
Well that got dark.
Uh,
just hit me.
I remember that.
That's why she's fucked.
Okay,
good.
No,
but,
but it would be interesting we're
talking about that other guy with all the
money in the Oregon.
Like if someone did that today,
like some are Kelly type guy.
I'm not saying our Kelly's a good guy.
I'm not saying what he's doing is legal.
But what I am saying is it is possible.
I don't think this is the
case in this situation,
but just as a what if it is possible
that you get together with a bunch of
people who are really ended
that slave dominatrix type deal.
Like some people are really
into being dominatrices.
Some people are really into
being submissive and they
get together like with it,
as long as it's men and women,
we don't have a problem with it.
Right?
Like if as long as it's some guys like a
CEO that hire some mistress to kick him
in the balls and stomp on
them and do it happens.
If we were totally cool with that,
people survive that.
That's a good question.
Just take the pain.
Some people like getting kicked in the
balls and need in a bones like repeatedly
and it's hard as you can.
I know they used to come into the club
and I used to work at and girls used to
get paid to knees in the lap dance.
They would just need the
shit out of their bubble.
I don't get it.
Maybe that pain,
that feels like death to most people.
It feels different to other people that,
that,
that that's like a rush can imagine if
that when you get hit in the balls into
that intense pain.
It's like a saying,
it's not like nothing else like stomach.
Yeah.
It's a unique pain.
But there might be people that take that
unique pain and turn it into like just
this high for you.
Yeah,
you're right.
It'd be a real why psychos people
that are into it Pumpkin to
watch that shit on Youtube.
Frank had a good point.
We came to fade or the time that is his
losses and we come to the states saying
how he never trains in a cage.
It's true.
Yeah.
It was the cage a factor in any of his
losses because two of them relative to
how,
what happened the do with fight Henderson,
he couldn't get out of the way.
The Henderson fight.
You couldn't get out of the
way in the Purdue fights maybe,
but Henderson fight Reese control
the ring ring is more fluid thing.
That's right.
The Henderson fight,
he hadn't been so I control
and Henderson and uh,
under them popped out with the under hook.
He wasn't careful with that.
With the under hook,
he had them side control.
If you don't have that under hook and the
guy on the bottom shoots the under can
get the dog fight.
It's true from side control.
You don't even need
quarter Gardner half car.
But if I'm fade or that's like a
tennis player only playing on grass.
So he's going to play on
clay with the fuck you dude.
What the fuck is going on?
18 can you not find the goddamn kitchen
rush was times where he didn't want to
fight anymore.
So the question is,
is he fighting now because of money?
Is he fighting now because he doesn't
know what else to do or is he fighting now
because he's got to reignited feeling
about competition and he likes it again to
go work security for Putin.
Get paid bro.
They're bull shit.
That's a good call.
Good call.
He's your right hand man.
He's gonna fuck with
freight or rush doors there.
Yeah,
I mean that would be,
I mean,
he's got to be a hero and rock dude.
Did you think of it going
on or in war with Russia?
Syria strikes.
No thoughts for a second.
I didn't think were going to war
with everybody thought I'm scared.
Anytime bombs dropped though.
Anytime bombs,
you're opening up the possibility
of bombs dropping back.
It's just like,
you know,
I mean,
even if what happened,
what did the people on the other side
of the dropping the bombs on deserve it?
It's still like,
Holy Shit,
we're in a fight.
You know anytime that happens,
if you're not legitimately concerned
that horrible things come out of it,
but the idea of us going
to war with Russia,
I'm like,
probably not.
Fuck man,
I just crazy.
I was in New York for that.
I got to,
Holy Shit.
I don't know what is going on
when it comes to foreign policy.
I would be a joke if I pretended,
which I have many times in my life.
You don't know.
I mean,
who the fuck knows what's happening
with Russia or with China?
I've been talking about this a while,
way thing.
Um,
Huawei is a big time cell phone or
electronics company in Japan or in China
rather.
And uh,
the State Department has
recently recommended you
don't buy Walway products and
that they might be a
bad actors and you know,
spying on the people that own their phone.
So they,
they canceled deal with Huawei to be
an 18 t and Verizon and all these other
cell phones,
you know,
providers here in the
United States and they,
there,
they literally issued a warning.
I was like,
I've never heard of that before.
And then there was something about,
um,
some sort of hacking that they,
they did,
they're going to take them to
court prosecuting for something.
They deal with Iran.
This is another thing about it,
but then I've heard people online say
that they're suspicious that what this is,
is trying to squash China from entering
into the electronics market is like the
top three people in cell phones are apple,
Samsung,
and Huawei is number three worldwide.
That's a thing to stop.
Wowway in America would
be like an economic thing
because they're worried about
China increasing the
amount of money they have.
Who can they believe?
But you know it's hard if
you're interested in following
Q a on a lot of people
analyzes drops,
but there's a youtube
channel called just informed,
uh,
Justin form.
Something just informed,
but he breaks it down every day.
He talks about all that stuff.
So it's all interesting because you got
to know that if Justin for coming to me
is that big.
And here's the thing that the,
the super dorks like Jamie and I've been
going back and forth about this because
the super dorks online,
I say that with all due respect to
dudes are really understand cell phones.
They're calling bullshit
because they're like,
if they were spying on you,
these guys who develop
apps and understand phones,
these,
these like super type dudes,
they'd be able to find the code.
They'd be like,
Yo,
this shit,
this shit spying on you.
It's listening to you.
Here's,
here's what the code,
this is what it's doing.
Microphones set to one set of design
is as good as the Russian hackers are.
Wherever in the world
the best aren't America.
Whatever they can do,
we can fuck best everything.
Right.
So that's why I was or
what the fuck it is.
We're best at suck America.
Drop a bomb eaten steak,
American drag and bear frag mayor.
Well it's got to go
get in the book but just informed talk
is the youtube channel than breaks down
Killeen on if you are interested.
It's really good.
It's very interesting
predictions whether this fight,
that's a good question.
Um,
man,
um,
I think they're both at very
similar places in their career,
which is one of the reasons
why this fight is interesting,
frank.
It's been up for a hot minute.
Sometimes when you get in
there and you fed lung left,
just say fucking throw
caution to the wind.
So it could be super quick.
Why did frank get released from UFC?
What happened?
Do we know?
Didn't he do some tests positive?
He tests positive.
His last one,
how long ago was that?
That was a while ago.
He's been off for.
He got compensated as a common state.
Wanted to kill Brock Lesnar.
Literally Kill Them.
Yes.
Fair enough.
He was a really good commentary,
great commentator who was really good.
It's compensating now for ACB.
What's ACB like that?
That Russian league.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
He's the head.
Come to NBC.
Be Interesting.
Interesting.
But we went to Frank's last fight.
He got knocked up by
Mark Hunt and then he,
they let him go.
I remember when he knocked
out Todd Duffy though.
Oh whoa.
That was crazy.
Great.
Great near still showed in that fight
that against a dangerous guy like Duffy
Frank's fall in love with his box and man,
I hate hearing that.
Well,
I mean,
he's a smart dude.
If you,
if you got to think his
Jujitsu is on point.
He's so smart.
He's very smart.
Very well read.
Him and Josh Barnett,
I think are the two smartest
heavyweights that I've ever met.
It's a good call.
Josh Barnett.
Very smart.
Very cerebral.
How's it?
Good fight.
Yup.
Josh Barnett Mirror.
Oh,
I'm a Josh Barnett.
Had it,
had him against the fence.
He was had great head position and forum.
Josh Schwab is out.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
It's a great fight for you Josh.
But yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Just overall it was a five rounder,
wasn't it?
I believe it was fine.
Ended pretty quick.
Josh whooped.
Is that,
oh no,
no,
no.
I'm thinking of another top speed is Josh
beat his ass and knocked him out with
a neat,
right.
Josh fucked him up and fucked him up.
I'm thinking of another fight
where Josh went five hard rounds.
Was it against DC when unbroken ahead?
No,
no,
no.
He beat somebody in a
very impressive fight.
Oh,
it was Roy was big country.
Oh yeah.
He took him down.
But he kept,
he kept taking down.
Yeah.
That was it.
That was a long shit out of Roy.
He beat the shit out of Roy
and it was a long fight,
right?
Wasn't it like a five rounds?
Uh,
I don't know if it's five rounds.
Three rounds of an ass whooping though.
See,
if you find that jam is a month,
he's a bad motherfucker.
He's bad mouthing him.
Him and frankly the most
cerebral I think to ever.
That's why Travis Brown's elbows are so
fucking impressive that he put him out.
He gets Josh out.
It's weird when Josh Russia,
because Salt Gonzaga to
get stopped like that.
Then he did the same thing.
I think he got clipped with
a punch before he rushed.
I think if I remember correctly,
I don't remember correctly,
but I remember those fucking elbows.
We to this day we call that
position the Travis Browne.
Yeah.
Is he done Josh?
Sorry.
I Dunno.
Um,
Josh Barnett and Roy Nelson.
He has a five round fight.
Five rounds.
No,
no.
I'm saying that kind of
fight made a main event.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Yeah.
I was amazed at van.
Yeah,
that's right.
It was overseas.
Yeah.
It was a beating man.
It was eating.
I was very impressed as cardio
and you'd pass forwards gun like,
yeah,
to frank does not look fat.
Right.
Just jacked man.
Why did I see,
I saw a photo of must have been
from in the past where he was heavy,
like maybe while they were setting this
fight up because like looking at him now
and he looks very fixed.
Great.
It looks very fit.
He's in studio with me.
I told him,
I said,
man,
you look shredded.
He's like,
I'm ready to go.
Wow.
I'm impressed.
He does look very fit,
so he must have been heavy
when he started at camp.
It's really heavy.
That's what it is.
He didn't fight for a little bit so you
know he's been commentating and flying a
Russia shit.
Interesting.
Here.
Here we go.
This is the only three rounds.
They don't do five round
main event only title fights.
Here we go.
What do you think about that?
I kind of agree with that.
Yeah.
I'm not mad at it.
I like firing rounds.
Three rounds.
That goes too quick.
I liked five round,
20 smaller weight classes,
so good point.
My thing would be,
man,
five round fights are beatings,
man.
I mean you really,
oh clipped him clover.
Oh said we're in trouble.
Not only surviving now.
Oh,
shit down.
He didn't frank.
He didn't have the under hook right there
again.
That's why frank stood up.
Oh,
Burgess.
Oh holy.
Oh Wow.
This can be a quick one.
I thought was gonna be a decision.
This is phenomenal.
If it's on.
Oh.
Oh Shit.
It's over.
That's it.
Oh,
what a war dance.
Whew.
Oh Wow.
You ready for this fade or chill?
Sewn in snacks.
Oh my God.
That's sinking.
Yeah.
That's actually fun.
That's fucking Kodak into happen.
Wow.
Frank Mirrors.
You know,
and he almost had him.
Almost had him.
What a great throat.
That is a great fuck fucking hip toss,
Huh?
That was beautiful.
Bottom some time dude
fade or chail sewn in.
Wow.
When was the last time fade?
Or one Maldonado,
but he really lost and Russia lost.
Yeah.
He got hurt and that fun.
That was crazy.
Flat.
I forgot about that one.
Yeah.
So let's,
I agree.
Won that fight.
He won it,
but he lost it.
So let's,
let's take it in Russia,
right?
Yes.
Let's take that one out of the equation.
He,
she damn,
that's right.
So Toshi,
which his last fight,
his retirement fight in his last run and
then decided to come back after that.
I'll do this
please.
All wild and loose.
Huh?
Boom.
Wait,
the left both.
Both hands down.
Damn.
What cloud this must be.
Oh,
they're the left hand.
Right on the chin.
Oh,
boom.
Boom.
Crazy hard shot.
Just swinging.
They're swinging wild going.
Oh Shit.
I feel like he caught them
earlier than that too,
but just that was the,
that was the big one.
The one that really hurt them.
Perfect stoppage.
God Damn,
there it is.
Oh,
it was the left.
Perfect left hand.
That was nice.
It's crazy.
This is fate or his first win
and take out the Maldonado fight.
She's how many years then?
How many years?
It's been a rough go for my man.
When was he?
She,
you felt beat seeing Jack Deep,
all that shit.
My brain,
my brain goes,
no,
that was when 15
new years eve.
2015 he also be Pedro his,
Oh,
on January 21st,
2012 that was,
yeah,
2012 shows after the
issue was 2012 oh yeah,
the,
the Pedro,
his Oh,
fight was a crazy knockout man.
That must have been in Europe.
So my rule,
a leg kick and then faked a leg kick
and landed a punch fade or started out
against,
I mean a guy we think about who's
got better leg kicks and Pedro,
his m one.
It was a Russian fight.
It was a ruthless knockout man.
See if you could find one.
One,
two,
three,
pull up Pedro,
his versus fate or John,
do you notice if you notice
anything or failures record there?
So he went on that fight,
fight winning streak.
It's none of it in the states before
that three in states states loses.
Is this,
this first one in the states?
Maybe Brett Rogers was his first.
Yes.
Was this was look at this.
Boom,
boom.
He threw a leg kick.
And before that did you,
was this the whole fight or
just a highlight real quick.
They edited it.
Yeah.
The video,
Jesus is still explosive.
He hit him with a leg kick first and then
he faked the leg kick and came in with
that punch.
If you came at that right hand and left,
took behind it and he's,
he's still explosive man.
Oh yeah man.
Tonight he was explosive.
Look,
he's still,
he's still fucking fade
or I mean you still,
he's a legend for sure,
but you're tapping him in the jaw
and he'll go down like a regular guy.
He is a regular guy in that regard.
Now all the fights that he's had,
all the wars,
the fact that he's in
his late thirties right?
41 he's 41 wow.
I thought it was flood.
I'd love to see that some never happening.
So it's stupid for me to say it
Francis and gone and or oh my God.
Why would you want to see that?
Cause they both just slamming them things,
but how do you think that fight would go?
I think,
I think Francis knocked his head
into Russia or Brock Lesnar fate.
Or
if I was,
if I could,
if I had,
if I had like a willy Wonka golden ticket,
like just gave it to you
and I gave it to you,
I would say Brock Lesnar versus who,
who finances in Ghana
and the posters.
Just old school.
It'd be so sick.
I liked that.
A thing about Brock can win
if he lands a take down,
but good luck not getting clipped
coming in such a dynamic fight.
It's nice scene fade or wind man.
I gotta say,
I mean,
I love Frank Mir.
I'm a Frank Mir fan and somebody had a,
when she was kind of Nice hail him,
he door.
I like it.
I liked that a lot.
The biggest fight Beltour history.
It's a very good fight,
man.
It's a very good fight and chills going
to talk some mad shit fade or doesn't
sell fights and wars.
He's just off his name.
That's what frank was saying.
He goes,
dude,
the media tour,
I have to do everything fatal.
Refuses to do interviews now.
He doesn't do interviews.
Yeah,
well I get it.
He doesn't speak English,
they call it.
Yeah,
I figured it out.
Motherfucker.
The new fans like who,
who while they know him now.
I see.
I think even amongst the,
the new fans,
this is like,
I mean he's essentially like a
Reggie Jackson type character.
If you know baseball,
you know who Reggie Jackson,
even if you don't know a lot about them,
you know who Reggie Jackson
and if you're new to the sport,
you're like,
this guy's the best of all
time seeing this stuff,
but they don't realize it's days.
Well,
you got to go back and watch
the first Nogueira fight.
Father Cro,
cop fight or you know,
even the Kevin Randleman
by when he got clipped,
the Kevin Random,
one's a great one suplex and then I just
a few moments later catches his arm.
Nasty.
Yeah man.
Very,
very,
very interesting.
She's,
she's been translating for fade
order for 20 it just flies her.
Yeah.
Maybe that's his girl.
She goes out back.
She puts a make America
great again hat on.
They catch her a or his locker
after where she's wearing the mag.
If I was a manager,
I would make everybody a camp
where it just for the press be too.
I'd be like,
put it on,
man.
He's the president United States.
What's the fucking problem?
Awareness about Kanye.
He's crazy.
He weird it,
but I mean,
come on man.
How good would that be if all of fate
doors camp including fade or had those
read Maga hats on?
That shit would be hilarious.
So bad if they were trolling,
that'd be great.
Tell you what man.
Your boy mitre own.
I mean that's a giant wind for him.
That was a giant when when
he came I would fade or,
well,
now Matt fights the winter of Bater Chemo.
That's a tough fight.
Tough fight.
It's a tough fight.
Fight for Matt.
Matt,
you know if he's got an issue at all,
it's not in his foot work or
as knockout power is movement.
It's if the fight goes the
ground like it was resting.
Here we go.
I want to hear what channels to say.
Crank that shit up,
Jamie.
This can be great.
Look at it.
Say someone who'd be in Russian,
it will not be bored.
His trash talking.
So old school,
it's very pro wrestling.
It's just not very good.
How do the Russian thing in is for this
damn Chilson is pretty fucking big.
Yeah,
failure is a small dude.
Okay.
That's why was a heavyweight.
He goes,
yeah,
very interesting.
God.
I thought,
you know what?
I expect more chill.
I thought he'd be like,
just one thing I hate more
than being this gauge.
Do it's all Russian in this gauge.
The Trump,
yes.
It pulls out a Mac.
Got Married.
Wait,
when is a fighter going
to come out with a,
I mean,
has there ever been a time where you
get more shit for liking the president?
Never even close.
Not even close.
I mean at the very least,
even if you didn't want him to win,
now that he's the president,
would you not want him to succeed?
What do you want?
Why do if he succeeds,
it means we succeed.
You want everything to be a catastrophic
failure because your guy didn't win,
or do you want him to get better at the
job and be really good at what he does
and be the best president that he can be
and pull a bunch of shit on what he did
with North Korea?
What's up with that?
Maybe he did.
I mean maybe it was a part of it.
We're both North Korea and South Korea
giving Donald Trump all the credit.
That's amazing.
If that's true,
that's amazing on CNN.
He,
that alone shows you that his unorthodox
style that you might be terrible if
you're married to them or terrible if
you're doing business with them are
terrible if you're his
lawyer or terrible whatever,
but that unorthodox style
might have value to it,
but no one wants that value
because you don't want him to win
because it's a fucking weird time.
It's like routine.
It's almost like you're rooting against
America because you feel so strongly
about the press.
Like to your point,
would you rather have him out?
You want the economy,
you better.
Here's he's the other thing.
You want Mike Pence to be president.
Are you sure you don't
know what you just said?
You don't know what you're saying
like that is not a smart choice.
That's not what you voted for.
It's now what you want.
What you should want is even
if you don't like Donald Trump,
what you should want is that
he does a great fucking job.
He turns the economy around,
he goes after child pedophiles,
he goes after like whatever,
whatever,
fill in the blanks,
whatever thing you would like them to do.
Even if he talks crazy shit about and
it gets on Fox and friends and says a
bunch of nutty shit,
wouldn't you still want that guy to
do the best job running the country?
This is where things get weird
cause I think most people say no.
I think if they say yes,
they're lion what they want
and they want them to fail,
they want them to be the worst
ever because they watched.
That's what they want.
That's what they want to flaw.
That's a crazy way of thinking.
But I didn't vote for Donald Trump,
but I want him to do great because
he's the fucking president.
Like either someone else comes along
that's better and wins and takes over,
or why would I,
why would I want everything to go bad
even if I didn't vote for so retarded?
Everybody,
if you had a doctor,
this is a good example.
Not,
not,
maybe,
maybe it sucks,
but if you had a doctor and
the doctor was a Dickhead,
the doctor's fucking annoying,
but he had to fix your knee.
But you know he's the
best at fixing knees.
Like this guy's a Dick dickhead.
I hope he fucked my knee up.
And people are,
you can never say that it's only
hurting you is the only guy can do this
operation for any of you.
Got to listen to me.
I know the guy's an asshole.
Let him operate on your knees,
going to do a great job.
He's going to talk shit.
He's going to try to fuck your mom,
but he's going to do,
here's a video.
Get it to people that hate Trump,
accused them of being racist and there's
a video of ice Q 50 said Shaquille
O'Neal,
like five or six celebrities
and now Kanye West that a,
they don't think he's racist.
Donald Trump is bad ass.
He's well,
he tells it like it is.
The question is like,
was he,
when he talked about Mexicans
on the campaign trail,
was he playing to people that are white
supremacists and what does he understand
that he has a base in those people
and does he defend that base?
That was about Charlottesville to correct
because he was saying that on both
sides there's,
there's problems on both sides.
Both the protesters and the KKK,
you gotta just and sometimes,
and he was right there on was problems on,
on both sides,
but they were there because
of a white supremacy rally.
And the most important point is that
that alone is a ridiculous way to think.
And that as Americans,
we can't tolerate someone who only likes
people that come from the same part of
the world is dam or people that only have
the same color skin is then where the
white race or the pure race,
because that's stupid.
It doesn't even fit up with
what we know about Iq standards.
If we really wanted the master race
we would be all trying to be Asian.
Okay.
Cause they dominate in Iq to the
point where they're suing Harvard.
Right now there's Asian,
there's an Asian American group that's
suing Harvard because the standards for
Asians to enter Harvard are more
stringent than even white people.
They're harder because they're
better because they get,
they get in more because their
brains work better than yours.
But see this is not,
this is not a popular narrative.
You know,
like people don't talk about this but,
but,
but no one,
no one's saying that.
You know.
So if you're,
if you're out there saying that
the white race is superior,
you're not even paying attention
to the facts this term.
No,
no.
But you got Lysol for sure not.
But the whites premise is,
and they want general population
think that Trump thinks like that too.
There's,
that's not true.
There's no evidence of that.
That's what they thought.
There is evidence that he understands
that he has a base and that his base is
white people.
There's a big part of it is white
people that are fed up about political
correctness.
Why people that are fed up about being
said they're racist just because they're
white and he knows black
people that want to hand out.
Like there's a lot of racists that have
a welfare prob problems that people that
are on welfare,
they're taken our money,
they've taken our jobs.
There's a lot of that going on
and he knows that those people,
there's a percentage of those
people that I'm sure support him.
So you gotta be real careful in the sand.
He plays to that side.
Yeah.
But no one's saying he's got,
there's any evidence that he's like that.
But he did say racist shit about Mexicans.
Right.
When he was talking about how the
rape and murder and the like the,
you know like someone's doing the
raping and murdering the crime,
the crime of course out of control.
But he's not being honest about that.
Okay,
so if one that's obvious
that he's trying to win,
right?
Cause if it's being honest about that,
what he would say is the reason why
there's so much crime is because drugs are
illegal.
If we may drugs legal,
we could sell these drugs to these people
in America would be run by businesses
instead of being run by the mob that did.
The demand is undeniable.
It's undeniable.
There's a demand for cocaine,
heroin.
There's also a demand for alcohol
is also a demand for plenty.
Plenty of things that are
bad for you in America.
Zr once you go about go buy 770 horsepower
corvette zero one that goes zero to
60 in 2.9 seconds and just drink
all the fucking red bulls you want.
Get on the highway and stomp the
gas and you're in a space ship.
That's crazy too.
That's all crazy.
So is doing heroin or you probably
might die more driving a zr one like an
asshole.
Then you would be doing coke,
but just going to kill more people in.
That's the other one.
You might look,
you might look,
there's still a lot of ways people can
fuck up their life and other lives around
them that are absolutely illegal,
but we just make this decision
that once something is illegal,
like drugs and I don't
think you should do coke.
I don't think you should do heroin,
but I don't think you should.
I don't think you should fucking
drink til you're dead either.
And people are doing that every day.
We're,
we're hypocrites in that regard.
And this idea that the only reason why
these people were over there raping and
murdering is because they're Mexican.
That's racist.
That's what you're saying.
It's a 20 Mexico.
Someone over there is doing it,
but why are they doing it?
I'll tell you why.
And you know why they're doing it.
Because drugs are illegal.
That's how the cartel makes their money.
What do you think about building a wall?
Crazy.
We shouldn't build a wall.
You shouldn't have secure borders.
We should do is help Mexico.
We should.
We should figure out some way and one
of the best ways to help them would be
make drugs.
Legal could be one of
the best ways to talk.
Not the one would recognize that.
What Mexico is just like,
like how is Mexico in terms of
like the amount of distance,
how were they?
It's close as they are to us.
Not Us,
but New York is us.
You can get to it in Mexico in two hours.
Dude,
you could drive to Mexico
from La in two hours,
but that's the eyes are not a country.
I didn't even us,
but we decided that Maine is us.
That shit is way the fuck over there.
These people are tagged to us.
They're right there.
They're connected.
You could walk there.
It's not outrageous to
match up more mess sources.
The right
people.
Nations are ridiculous.
One one world government.
No,
not even a government man.
We should have rules that we all agree on.
Our problems are as the boys
teams go against other teams.
But if we're all on the same team,
then we compete against each other
economically the way we do in cities.
That's why we don't have wars in cities.
We don't have city wars.
Right.
The reason why we have
wars with other countries,
because we think of each other
as being on another team.
There's crime in cities,
but there's crime and countries.
But we really need is to abandon this
idea that we're all in these fucking
tribes.
And I'm not saying I support
one side or the other,
but it,
when Trump was saying that,
isn't the law,
the violences from the Mexican cartels
and stuff in America and the some of it,
yeah,
a lot.
Salvadorians no,
it's 100% real,
but it's propped up by trucks and until
you address the root of what gives them
money,
causes the violence,
and I'm just talking nonsense.
So the primitive way to approach it is
to say this team is going to go against
that team.
So we're going to put up a wall of heat.
That team from coming over here.
That's not going to help.
They're still going to drink.
If you want to look at the entire
future of people the entire future,
it's eventually going to come to a point
where there's going to be an easy way.
You know there's,
there's,
they have these pixel and
the Google Pixel phone.
They have these ear buds that allow you
to translate someone's language in real
time.
So if you were talking to me in Spanish,
I could hear it through these ear
buds for the Google Pixel phone,
the Pixel two and it would
translate so I could go to Mexico,
I could talk to some
cat who knows Spanish.
He and I could talk and he could,
I could understand what he's saying.
It's going to come a point in time
where that is way simpler language.
It's going to be all the same language.
And then it's like,
why is,
why is there a war with Mexico
and not a war with North Dakota?
Why?
Why am I not on the same team
as someone in fucking Tiawana,
which is right there.
Why am I not,
not just like those people?
Why are we on different
teams says who says why?
What benefit is that?
This is some old school
shit that we only needed,
cause he didn't know what the fuck people
are doing because it was like vikings.
They would show up in both
start raping and murdering two,
but they're not doing that to the
people that are in their village.
Right.
They're not doing that to each other.
Well,
they do it because they
think people or the other.
So this idea of the other
and the idea that tribe,
it's an outdated idea.
It's an outdated idea that it may be.
It's not time.
It's times not done now,
but its time has done in a
hundred years or a thousand years.
The future is people,
just people.
It's not Germans versus the French
versus the Russians versus the Italians.
That shit is retro.
It's stupid.
It's just like,
it's just like tribes of fucking ancient
hominids just sneak it in when they
didn't even speak languages and club
at each other and raping each other and
doing all the shit that
people have done forever.
Plus California,
Arizona,
and Texas were Mexico.
How about California's trying
to separate into three spots.
I know.
Yes.
That's going to be on the ballot.
It's going to be on the ballot in what?
2020 is that what it is?
They can cause wins.
What happens?
There's going to be,
it's going to be fucking California south.
Really?
This is going to be la.
He was going to be one that's going to
be like California and then there's going
to be like southern California,
like San Diego way up to like,
you know like Bakersfield or some shit.
It makes sense though if you're,
if you're gonna do,
if you're going to go
off the old game plan,
the old map,
it makes it so big.
This is why it makes taxes.
If you drive from La to San Francisco,
you drive through Kentucky.
I don't know how it happens,
but the,
the you,
you drive by God is great
signs and don't have abortions.
Here's a doctor or this
is Jesus loves you.
It's farm land.
It's not what you think it is and
it's nothing wrong with Kentucky.
I'm talking about it's,
it's rural.
It's rural.
Beautiful.
Yeah,
it's,
but it's rural.
It's farm land.
Like there's a big part of
California that's farms.
Yeah.
But isn't it,
isn't it?
The South is the one struggling in
the north is killing it right now.
We sending another,
it's political man.
It's all political.
Right?
But it's not that anybody's killing it.
It said the,
the con they don't feel represented.
See,
there's more people in San Francisco and
in Los Angeles by far than the rest of
the state.
But the state is huge.
Like,
you know,
it takes,
you drive from,
everybody thinks it's San Francisco
is northern California the fuck it is.
There's a,
there's hours of driving
until you hit more northern.
How many hours did it take to
drive from San Francisco to Oregon?
I want to say four.
I think so.
I'll say three somewhere.
I'll say a little bit more.
I'm going to say to four and a half.
I'm gonna say two and a half hours.
Was it Saint James?
Okay.
Um,
I,
I'm saying for sticking
to for you might be right.
I'm just guessing,
but it's fucking,
it's a grip of space.
Five hours.
See there's a lot of fucking space up
there and those people are all rural.
It's like that's where like the Green
Emerald Triangle is and Humboldt and a
grown all the fucking weed.
Beautiful as beautiful up there.
It's like a rain forest
dude.
I've been to many,
many parts of northern California.
It doesn't even remotely
resemble Southern Cal.
Hell No.
So these people didn't feel represented.
Alleys all goofy.
It's just,
you know,
they feel like this is just some liberal
delusional hotbed and they also don't
like a lot of the laws,
the laws in regards to wildlife
management mosques is like if he live in
Sacramento wiping the same tax
as someone that lives in Malibu.
Yes,
the taxes are off the charts here.
They were saying that 500,000 people
this year going gonna move out of
California in New York because
of taxes just because of tax.
But say he was a bit more than if you
live in Oxnard should be paying the same
tax zone,
beach front property.
How fucked up is that?
No,
it makes no sense.
But you aren't.
You paying more if you live in
Malibu because you're paying more,
you make more money.
So you're,
you're a higher percentage
of your property.
You know,
your,
your property's worth more.
Yeah.
But still,
you're still a high fucking ready to feed,
not to live in California.
The rates ridiculous.
Crazy.
Well,
you know,
also,
it's ridiculous when you realize
you don't have to pay that rate.
If you go other places,
like I know guys who've moved,
what's the,
Florida is pretty good.
Texas.
Florida is good.
If you have a business,
you know,
like I know guys that have businesses
that move to Florida because if they sell
their business,
they don't want to pay
13% to the government in
California and they can't text.
This is good thing happens.
Um,
there's a lot of places
we don't pay state tax,
Washington,
you know,
pay state tax,
Nevada,
you don't pay.
State tax might be,
I think when I'm reading right now says
this is not just the plan to split the
state.
It's the split away from the United
States to make it so much of that plan.
Some wacky dude.
I love,
definitely luxury.
I can have,
I believe in luxury.
That's not,
that's not happening.
So that's how the Lord of the texts,
the big one where the business people
or people that want to save the money,
but the United States is fascinating in
a way that you could find out where the
laws are best for you.
And you go,
look,
we're just going to fucking take
a chance and moved to Montana.
You know,
you,
you live in Montana,
you're living in a place where like 3
million people instead of 30 million
people.
You live in a place where you're like,
uh,
butted up against the fucking Yellowstone
park and looking at mountains and
shit.
And yet we're just at night.
Is it true that you could take the world's
population and fit them all in Texas,
all in their own house?
Yes,
that's true.
That's really true.
That's true.
Yeah.
How crazy is the Texas is gigantic.
Well,
but we're talking about all of China
and all of Africa in Texas with everyone
else.
There's some things about and saying
there's something about Texas where,
is that true?
Yeah,
that's true.
I amount of European countries,
you fit in Texas.
It's kind of crazy.
You know what?
The whole world can fit in
Texas with their own house.
Everybody with their own house.
That seems unbelievable.
8 billion a billion people.
People in Texas and their own house,
a billion houses in Texas.
You know,
Texas is a different state man.
It's not like any other state.
They were Alaska Kulik you could do the
same thing in Alaska if everyone lived
in a 10 by 10 room.
Yeah.
Well,
Alaska is the biggest,
and Texas is the second pig is right,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Doesn't it seem,
if that's the case,
then the overpopulation is a myth.
It's gotta be no,
it's not a myth because it's
about the resources in space.
You could jam everybody in Texas,
but it would be like Mad Max.
There'll be funnel Carolyn still,
it'd be like there's no,
and the rest of the world is,
you'd have to grow food in the rest of
the world and people would be socking it
out and truck loads each other.
That'd be on top of each other.
I don't know.
No.
Overpopulation is not a myth.
Eddie overpopulation is right.
Everybody in Texas,
it's a math.
No,
no,
no.
Here's the thing.
First of all,
it's not sustainable.
This is the problem with
overpopulation right now.
We're okay if we just kept this number.
The human race could survive.
The real problem is we're
not keeping this number sign.
No,
this number's going to grow.
This number was 2 billion.
Whatever the fuck it was in
1950 and it's 7 billion now.
The voice,
it's the resource having less kids though.
Now I have so many friends in
the forties and have no kids.
It's not like it wasn't the fifth
shiner swirled swirling countries.
That's one of the things
about the rest of the world.
They're outbreeding US radically will not.
In Japan there's,
there's been studies.
Every time I'm on a plane,
I see emptiness in barren wasteland.
Everywhere I go,
I don't see like over,
it's true relation.
I see emptiness everywhere had that.
He has a point here,
people and you fly over the country,
but there's places where
you can't grow shit.
Eddie,
like you're flying over
Nevada and you're looking down
and you got to look.
What they did with Vegas is they
tricked everybody to thank you.
You could live in Nevada,
don't pay fucking fucking made that.
They made Henderson,
they made Vegas.
They basically built these places in a
place they shouldn't have built places.
They found they had a crazy rule.
They could do whatever
the fuck they want there.
There's the loss.
What's weird about Nevada is
Nevada has two weird things.
One nuclear testing.
They did a fuck load of nuclear testing.
You see the fucking,
there's a map or a video rather that shows
you the map of the earth and it shows
you all the nuclear bombs they set off
in Nevada and you're just like Macaulay
Culkin from alone by the end of the video.
Like what do you remember those old uh,
uh,
nuclear test videos where they
show like a building and then like,
I like this hurricane of
nuclear energy going through it.
Like what everybody remembers now,
right?
Like how did they film that?
They set cameras up.
How does the camera's dialed?
They had to be seen as they've
set kind of cameras are those,
listen,
they're very far away when all the
shit is going down and here's the,
the,
the scariest thing is not those buildings
blowing and parts they do because they
got hit so hard.
The scariest thing is the ones when
you see the bombs and the distance that
miles away and these guys jump on,
they jump up at the shit
goes over their head,
they're in these ditches and they jump
up and run towards it because they didn't
know shit about radiation back then.
So they had these soldiers practice with.
The idea was that you would drop the
nuclear bomb on people and then they would
run towards the bomb because the people
would be so fucked up and disoriented
that you just take over the city,
Jesus Christ.
But meanwhile,
these people were running right into
radiation grown like three eyeballs walk
them.
People in Vegas aren't
born with three heads.
What's not vague?
Some are,
it's still,
it's not as big.
Nevada's big.
Yeah.
But those nuclear test sites are
not that far from Vegas where it,
they're blowing up these
nuclear bombs all the time.
People in Vegas should be growing
fucking three dicks for the next thousand
years.
You know there,
there is a story about John Wayne
that John Wayne was filming a movie.
Now when you're going
to need you on this one,
Jamie,
the John Wayne was filming a movie in
like the 1950 [inaudible] whatever the
fuck it was.
He was doing those westerns
and that during that time
they were in an area where
they were doing tests,
nuclear tests,
and everybody on that
movie set got cancer.
Everybody say that again.
What does it,
what does it say there?
The movies so toxic.
It killed John Wayne.
The tragedy of the conqueror.
Yeah,
that was about him.
It wasn't that king is how to
know that movie killed them.
I mean like how would they know when
people are getting cancer all the time?
No,
but I think a bunch of people got cancer.
We're getting cancer
from the polio vaccine,
like all of them.
Got It.
Did you know that that like a million
people for the vaccine from the polio,
let's to say Jamie.
I'll find the more,
I don't even know if this is a truth.
You know that you know
that and you've heard that?
Yes.
I don't know if this is a true story.
I need to,
I need to drop some knowledge
to not drop the no knowledge.
I'm keeping it fun today.
I know,
but it's good points when you're flying.
I fly nonstop flat population.
No Lou Shit.
It's the price.
You'd have to turn all that shit into
farmland to females as people don't know
about that.
I don't know.
Just dirt.
It's just dirt.
There's definitely room.
The question is for how long and how much,
how many people can
you feed off that dirt?
Like if you're in Nevada,
how many farms are in Nevada?
Was the cocker,
what does it say?
Scroll up.
Conquer.
Filmed on a nuclear test site.
Good move.
Yeah.
Howard Hughes,
the Director and Bill Powell knew of the
dangers and had written assurances from
the Atomic Energy
Commission that it was safe.
But apparently that's even John
Wayne supposedly brought a Geiger,
I don't know.
This might have been too
long ago to get accurate.
John would con yellow face terrible.
Super Racist.
It's so terrible.
You watch it and he's like,
Oh,
I'm gang guys caught
[inaudible] bout that takeover
that China to I hate old movies,
man.
I'm fighting so bad for John Wayne's
the winds the best move all the time.
Fuck.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
Hold on.
What does it say,
Jamie?
A lot of people got cancer on the set.
Oh Wow.
How many people?
90 of the 220 person crew did.
46 of those people died.
Uh,
some of the,
all the main actors apparently all died
of cancer within 25 years of the movie
coming out.
You might be able to say that about any,
no.
I mean,
so many people die of cancer.
Isn't cancer the number one killer?
Isn't everybody the cancers out there?
That's a high break,
dude.
That's not like this,
like go back Jurassic Park.
Everyone's still alive.
Those that may amaze,
you know,
it'd be a lot of people like now,
even today,
these nuclear bombs were
going off in the 50s it's,
I don't understand who's always a
conspiracy guy doesn't recognize this
conspiracy that these dummies didn't
understand what the fuck they were doing.
They did.
Is conspiracy because they buddy up about
this on youtube.com was that how stuff
works?
That's mainstream right there.
That's the stuff.
works.com that's as
mainstream as you can get.
What does that mean?
You know what's mainstream?
The jre.
This is mainstream.
It's fun.
As mainstream as fuck.
So what does that mean?
Downloads a day.
What does this mean?
Like what does mainstream mean?
It doesn't mean it's not real.
Just because,
you know what I'm saying is you said it
was a conspiracy theory and I'm like,
no,
that's not what I said.
I said,
the conspiracy to keep this quiet,
the fact that the government's nuclear
tests most likely killed John Wayne and a
shit load of actors from
fucking cancer in the desert.
They were dropping bombs,
not knowing what the fuck they were doing.
And there's plenty of evidence that
they didn't know what the fuck they were
doing.
If you've watched the videos
of old nuclear test site,
which soldiers running towards the blast
and have you seen those fucking insane
thing that looks like it looks like,
I don't know.
It just like all that old footage
looks like it doesn't look authentic.
It looks like they faked all that shit.
What about
nuclear bombs or fake?
Is that what you're saying to me?
I,
you know,
there's a conspiracy theory that uh,
um,
nuclear bombs actually don't exist.
That they never actually figured it out,
but they realized that the threat
of nuclear bombs as good enough,
the Eddie,
you can see the bottom,
but how do you ever see the one where
they dropped the bomb in the ocean and
they didn't know how much
of a blast it would create?
What I'm saying is this
fake this when they did it,
but all I'm saying is how do you know
it wasn't just a regular powerful bomb?
Like how do you know?
How do you know by watching a bomb go off?
How do you know what's nuclear nuclear
nuclear bomb looks like when it blows up?
I don't know.
There's irregular but don't
know how we listen to him.
Eddie,
listen to him.
We have things that can test nuclear,
but I'm saying how do you,
how can you tell?
I know that you can do,
you can do tests with those.
Insurance has never done.
I don't know.
Your studied in.
I'm saying I don't know.
I know,
but I'm saying I don't know.
Telling you how can people look at a bomb?
You're saying someone else figured it out.
How can you look at a bomb and
thinking about shit the wrong way?
Really do.
No,
I'm just saying if there was
videos of 20 bombs going off,
would you be able to pick
out the nuclear bombs?
Eddie,
they make these giant mushroom clouds.
They're very unusual.
It's not like a regular bomb.
I'm not saying pull that video
at the bottom of the ocean.
How can anybody tell like a
regular piece of that question?
I think you should probably
talk to a nuclear physicist.
Does asking questions.
I don't know,
but to question it like it's not real.
It's ridiculous.
They killed how many fucking
people in Nagasaki and Hiroshima?
How do you know what kind of bomb that,
watch this,
watch this bomb aren't they're still app.
Look at this.
I don't know.
How do you know if that's kind of bomb
that that is the craziest amount of power
you could ever imagine.
I could never imagine something that can
blow the ocean a mile into the sky and
that's just one video of it.
There's another one of those videos
where they do it from a distance.
You look at the water
where it's falling from.
I get,
see if he could find,
what do you understand?
It could be a nuclear bomb.
I'm saying all I'm saying.
How can you know for sure?
How can you,
how many whales died in this?
Oh,
everything died.
Everyone.
They all the fish.
They made some tuna salad
out of that motherfucker.
All the fish.
Fuck.
Look at the water.
Come down.
How crazy that is.
What the that boat's fuck though.
Huh?
Look at that.
Yeah.
I don't know.
If they don't know,
look at that.
That's,
that's high.
That's high.
That's big.
But I don't know why
quest inventional bombs.
It's,
well,
what it,
what differences?
Because Eddie's Eddie's sand.
The reason why they threaten nuclear
bombs keep everyone kind of chill,
but we might not have the,
they did.
They've got you don't to do that dude.
That would wipe out a fucking city.
But maybe you could do that with
just regular conventional bombs.
Maybe he just,
maybe that's like 10.
What you're saying is,
I don't know.
Well,
you should find out.
I don't know by this is,
this is a nuclear bomb.
Okay.
And the scientists all agree there's no
conspiracy conspiracy's amongst idiots
because people that are
talking about it online,
they literally have no idea what they're
talking about and they're spreading
this.
Don't know.
I understand.
I don't understand.
You don't know,
but don't even bother.
Question.
It's a waste of time.
It's a,
it's a,
you're going down a
rabbit hole for no reason.
It wastes all his time.
How do you know?
I don't need to know.
What do you care about me?
What's going on?
I go away.
I could waste my time on whatever.
Why?
Because I'm concerned.
Why are you so concerned
about me and wasting money?
Because you waste our time to why?
It's an interesting conversation
whether or not nuclear bombs,
we don't have to talk about.
Why don't you want to
find the answer to it?
Why did you just want to question it?
You could look up,
you could look up.
Yeah,
you could look up anything.
It's not going to look up.
If you will really want to know the
answer to this particular question.
You could look it up and I'm going,
no,
no library.
No,
no.
You could go to college.
You could get a professor.
You could find any number of
people that have the answers,
could show you how to study them.
Could prove the test too.
You could lay it out.
It could give you all of
these instructions so you
could go do it on your own
without anybody else
care about it that much.
Then why?
Again and Joe's Joe's point.
I just,
I just don't trust anything
I can verify for myself.
You don't have to get mad
at you because of that.
Why you mad?
Because you're getting mad right now.
I don't trust shit from the government.
You can verify this.
You just said you can't,
but you can.
That's,
that's the issue on some of
these things with science.
They are fair.
Yes.
I went to fucking
physics class at college.
I got an a,
so that proves the nuclear bombs.
I didn't make it to that fireworks.
I quit college.
I didn't keep going down the nuclear club.
That's farther in than physics
one 11 and one 12 at Ohio state.
They don't give it to
the freshmen high lows.
That's it.
I mean,
if you want the answers,
you can go get them.
It's not just question the world.
Why?
It's frustrating because
you don't want the answers.
You just want to question everything
that in air quotes government says
it's frustrating.
Why?
Because the world being flat because
nuclear bombs being fake because dinosaurs
not being real.
All those things are crazy.
They're a giant waste of time for who?
For us.
When we're talking to
talking about something,
no.
Okay,
but you will bite talking
about those things.
Hey,
I didn't bring up nuclear bombs.
You guys did.
I didn't bring it up,
but you really argued it for a while.
I'm just bringing up questions
and you're getting angry.
Not Angry at e.
Okay,
good.
Do you hear me being angry right now?
You guys sounded angry.
You said you were frustrated.
Frustration usually is,
is in there with anger.
Anger.
I'm just saying it.
The one fun point and
he was making is like,
man,
I don't know nuclear science
or anything like that,
so how do you know those that
I'm bumps a real computer,
regular bomb.
It was a fun conversation.
That's it just makes up a,
you're fucking calves.
Jamie got named seven tomorrow morning.
Turn in game seven the game.
You can look into a lot of this
stuff and you can't find the answers.
That's all I,
that's my only point and
when you're talking over me,
that's where the frustration comes from.
That's it.
You're angry.
I'm not angry.
You get angry at bed Stuy
town people to not get angry.
You using that as a defensive tactic
because he's making a good point because
saying people are angry.
Okay,
you,
you got,
you say it's frustrating.
So as we can say,
it's my angry because you don't
believe in the government.
You're angry.
I don't trust the government.
You could say that.
We can say,
why are you angry?
Do say that.
Now we could say that to you.
We can say why you angry.
That doesn't get anybody anywhere.
We're just talking about
the reality of these facts.
You guys can believe whatever you want.
Okay.
All right.
I will.
Okay.
I believe everything I've
been taught and learned,
go right ahead.
I think that doesn't frustrate me.
I don't care what you think,
but am I wrong then?
No,
you can believe whatever you want to.
Why would you continue to question that?
Hey Brennan,
that's a nice shirt.
Hey,
does that kind of goes in right?
Cheryl is flowers.
Floral is in right now.
Like Hawaii's track.
If you go to Hawaii,
make sure you wear a nice Hawaiian print.
It's in floral.
Joe and I ended up
wearing a Hawaiian shirt,
like with the buttons because it was
the only time you should wear soldiers.
They're in right now.
I used to wear those on
stage like an asshole.
Did you really thought they were cute,
Tommy,
but they're back now,
so he'd be good.
Oh,
they're back.
You know what's in.
Do you know?
Do you have any idea at
all what's fashionable?
Not at all.
No chance from 10 years
ago and the fact like,
I liked fashion,
but why are you into fashion?
I don't know.
Since I was a kid,
I was super into fashion.
I just love fashion.
Huh?
I don't know.
I couldn't tell you why collect
shoes like the trendy shit,
whatever's going on,
but you're one of the rare straight guys.
It's really,
I know you'd think I'd suck a ton of debt.
You conspiracy theory,
you really do enjoy it.
Love it.
Like you like funky shoes.
I said I got a job on either.
They're like,
well,
you're not gambling.
No,
I'm just super into fashion.
Girls like this that are in the fashion
generally and genuinely likes it.
Yeah,
I love it.
You like looking good?
I read about a Gq magazine,
all that stuff.
Oh Shit.
Oh
Shit.
You're special in Boston.
I raised the texts cause
I was gonna be like,
dude,
what are you going to wear?
And I was like,
I'm not going to send that to him because
that's funny.
That goes through my head,
man.
I've outfits picked out weeks before.
If I've,
if I have a show in a wait a minute,
shows in Minnesota,
have my outfits already picked up?
Damn.
Yeah.
Just terrible.
Always.
No,
it's your stuff.
It's not terrible.
It's not,
you don't dress like an asshole.
You make an effort.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
I work.
Shirts are too big for me.
They don't,
they don't fit me right.
I just wear a 10th planet shirts.
That's a good agency.
Sure that your business shirts,
they're free.
What do you do when your style dies off?
Do you get rid of the clothes?
Salvation Army.
You got to get coffee.
I'd get rid of,
I'd give it to salvation army.
I knew it.
So you're not even
stockpiling the old shit.
You don't be caught dead
with the most house,
your house?
Hell No.
How many pairs of shoes and
sneakers do you keep it at any time?
Probably have around 150 right.
I know
what young Jamie can relate to
that a hundred hundred 50 shoes.
Yeah,
that is so,
and then now you know what's happening
is I post on my Instagram story like sh
look kicks of the day or you know,
studio kicks and they'll come to me.
They're sending me shoes.
So I post on there.
It's a vicious cycle.
This Ninja warrior,
it's ridiculous.
It's Ninja Warrior Shit is going on
in between Scientology commercials.
When you guys are gonna look up earlier.
Fleas.
Herring.
Well,
how'd she do?
She didn't do good.
It's tough.
Unless it's your thing.
It's fucking tough man digging.
I'm sure it's not very,
you guys aren't gonna dig it.
Your wife wells,
that Peloton bike.
You liked that?
I fuck I on the couch.
I can do as good 45 minute class.
I only fuck with Robyn Nyc.
She's a little beast on there.
I refer refuse to use anyone else seated.
People love those things.
It's fun man.
I love him.
I still box and shit like that's
quit looking at me like that.
Any but I,
I jumped on a bike man.
Nothing wrong with that.
Yeah.
I like being outside,
man.
I like running hills so much.
My Cardio,
I try to do all outside that.
Um,
I have that rowing machine
thing and then the air bike,
my problem is like fuck
me on set at seven.
Let me until you leave the house at five
45 so I'll get up at four 30 knocked
that out.
So just someone else.
How often do you do fighter and the kid?
Twice a week.
And then big brown breakdown
below the belt podcast.
Monday mornings then shoot
brown breakdown anymore.
It's below the belts on.
Why'd you change it?
Uh,
they get a shot from time the
government came to forced,
they forced him.
I just made it all in sync
with the show on showtime.
First of all,
using big brown is now
cultural appropriation,
correct.
That.
I know they called you big brown,
but you can't use it anymore.
No.
Cause you're not brown enough.
Not Brown enough shame that a DNA test.
You get some 23 and me and find
out you got something menu.
Did you really get in trouble
for you as in big browns break?
Right then you might have some
you just didn't like it no more.
No,
I liked it.
I liked it,
but I was doing uh,
the,
I got my show on showtime.
Blow the bell.
So you kill him.
So the pot I didn't kill.
It's the exact same show.
I just want it all the same brand.
What if you had like
with rock below the belt?
So everything's below the
belt with Brendan Schaub?
Yeah.
Okay.
Come on man.
What Jamie show about death.
What do you,
what if you found out you
were like 18% Moroccan?
What?
You ever do one?
I was 23 and me's?
No,
you got some stuff in you.
I'd love to do that.
I'd love to find out if I was like,
I guess a 5% black and maybe like one.
Yeah.
That girl,
that girl,
um,
Whoa,
Vicki,
you've ever heard a wool?
Vicky,
the young girl,
she's,
there's,
there's this epidemic
of these young rappers,
these white young white rappers
that are completely insane.
Scroll and make you want
to pull your hair out.
She,
her name is,
she's just throwing money around.
She's a little white.
She's like 15 years old,
right?
Or something like that.
She talks like the ghetto is cute.
She's claiming she's part black
little Vicky.
Whoa,
Vicky.
Right.
A little tastes worse.
She's like 10 years old.
Bri.
Bri Up [inaudible] right?
She like,
y'all bitch,
but you watch this and you're like,
oh shit,
we're screwed down the road.
And they're huge.
They're huge.
Tokaji six,
nine you guys here it Tokaji six,
nine.
Oh my God.
They make some money off of youtube then
you guys just so we're screwed in terms
of the future,
the race,
because they're looking up to these,
these kids have millions
and millions of followers.
Oh they do?
It's like all they do is
bring out stacks of hundreds,
get on Instagram live and just
start throwing down the model.
She bought her house
and Copter Little Tag.
Well,
here's their fight.
She had a fight with somebody.
The cash me outside girl outside.
They all ran into each
other at the Glendale.
Let me see this.
Oh Shit.
That's,
Oh shit.
See if see the floral
floral.
She's 14
she's nine.
14 was nine yeah.
The floral print Hoodie is 14
says
she's trying to 6 million or nine year old
body guards to 20 Oh,
so this is not really a fight.
Are you looking to get into a fight?
Not Physically fight right here.
Yeah,
son.
You don't tease me Bro.
She just tries to reach over.
It's nothing major.
Yeah.
You got to show that
the white girl though.
I don't want to see the little girls.
Vicky just talking shit.
Throwing cat.
I got two racks on this car.
I've got the keys to this car.
What?
Yeah.
Beverly Hills area.
Licensed.
Okay.
That's what they do.
Crazy.
Huge.
They're rich.
5 million followers behind that.
The parents.
I don't know what's holding the camera.
I don't know what's going on.
Go to the white girl.
Think she's black,
but no,
Vicky did not seem super.
Did that seem like super rehearsed?
Yeah,
I don't get it,
man.
I don't know what's going on.
It's hilarious though.
This is,
well,
Vicky,
was she the other one?
There was the tall one that was in the
back of the tall one was she's the worst
one.
The worst one.
Your actual page?
No.
Yeah,
we'll,
Vicky talks so much and she
claims she's part black.
That that's her,
right.
Oh,
I saw that.
She wrote this nice
as kids.
They keep coming to about
me in a bad baby situation.
Yani know what really happened.
That bitch,
that bitch slapped me from behind
while I was on a persona on the ground.
Try and grab my purse.
Let me tell you,
sung this base way to I
was 18 to really fight me.
Like bitch we had before a whole year.
I just turned 18.
How could this whole fucking life,
she's huge.
I don't feel good right now.
She bought a helicopter mom.
Yeah.
She bought the fun serious helicopters.
Oh my God.
Oh,
Vicky.
Damn.
Kids are fucked.
Fucked dad.
And then that,
uh,
Takashi six nine guy,
he looks Mexican to me but he,
he's claiming,
I think he's claiming he's black,
right?
Cause all he says the word all the time.
All the time.
It's okay.
No one's kicking his ass.
Yeah,
it's totally a quarter Puerto Rican so
they can do that up there and do it.
He looks like a regular
Mexican guy from loose la.
It means,
can't say that,
but put her Riggins Ken,
how weird is that?
Have you,
have you seen him?
Have you seen him before?
He went on.
He has songs were in the courses where
he's using the and it's part of the
music.
Yeah.
He said he's going to do that
if you Puerto Rican down.
Yeah.
I think guys,
they got through some
rail grays law six
number one hits in a row.
He's killing it.
He has rainbow hair.
He's got Rainbow Grill,
he's going to rainbow grill now.
New Tattoo was 69 on his face and he
has done and also that monster from saw
that he has 69 [inaudible] 69 towards
Jamie forced me into watching him.
He has,
he has 69 tattooed 69 times on his body.
Is that the ones who
was the one who told me?
I think let me see his face.
The new grill.
Cause the new grill is off the charts.
It looks like a dude from east La
and me while we're talking about him.
So he wins.
Yeah he does.
But he's a terrible follow dude.
I watch every post.
What?
He's in trouble for.
For pedophile?
For 13 year old.
Come on.
Yeah,
he's catching a case.
How old is he?
That's what my friends say.
Catching case.
Catching a case.
You're like down the street.
Look,
he's got a spiderweb tattoo
and I was faced with that saga.
What's that saw guy's name
pinwheel or something like that.
Pinhead.
Scary Shit though.
Did anyone see the new salt?
Would that just that guy.
Jigsaw.
Look,
he's got 69 on his belly that
looks like markers on him.
He just lost is a $5 million headphone
yo cause of what happened at the Broner
fight.
What happened?
He was in a beef with Adrian Broner.
Who's that?
The kind of fight a boxer,
boxer bet and I guess somebody in his
crew and there was a beef with another
fee,
a rapper and a gun went off.
Oh,
it's the backstage lost.
He lost.
I said fun deal because damn it and how
many million dollars was hell phone,
$5 million for a headphone he does is
get on Instagram and just throw money.
I saw.
It's crazy.
It makes me watch and
he makes hits though.
That's what he's getting.
His money.
His fame.
Yeah.
Six number one songs in a row.
It's crazy world.
We live in a bravo fucking nuts.
Yeah,
go ahead.
Go to that middle one with his grill.
Look at that.
Click on that video.
Listen to them,
listen to them to that.
I want to show off these.
How can you chew what they got?
Like Shari by Jimmy boy.
You know what I'm saying?
He flexed up one on one,
but I want to make a public service
announcement freeze past couple of days.
I seem like there's a couple of females
that are trying to expose me as some
shit.
Like there's a lot of you like
I can't even name is a lot of,
you know,
like how a little bit more respectful
to ourselves and I say that in a,
in a way because I need to get past that.
It was just like a one day thing,
you know what I'm saying?
Okay.
I can't,
can you imagine if your
dollar brought that home?
You like,
what the f where'd you find that?
Go to home depot.
Is this music good?
I never,
no.
I've listened to clips of like,
you know,
I'm second.
Oops.
I'm old enough now where I don't know.
You'd have to.
It's not for me.
Go to home depot.
People are loving it.
They're eating it up door,
dude.
Get to do the music.
It's a whole error.
It's fucking,
you'd have to call the doctor.
You'd have to get a psychiatrist.
Is this a song?
Oh my God.
No,
no,
no.
I,
I can't,
we can't play it.
It'll get us take it off of Youtube.
Okay.
I can't,
I can't afford that anymore.
It might be great.
You never know the,
here's my question.
If this is ridiculous,
right.
What is,
what is the next thing after the shit?
Look at this mother flush robot.
Yeah,
and this guy is an engine.
That shit out of this stuff is hard.
We still look at it for a while.
We'll keep going.
Look at this motherfucker
on Ninja Warrior man.
I'm super impressed with the way
this dude is traversing this.
I think there are people that called
cultural preparation on this to Kashi sex
nine guy.
Oh really?
What do they call everything on everybody
making,
I don't know.
I don't know who's behind him either.
Like the managers at behind him and it's
a couple of other guys that are making
a shit load of money like them.
Is it a,
is it a producer project?
Is My planned,
did they pluck this guy and go,
okay,
this is perfect for our,
like he'd have to really get a God.
It's willing to tattoo his face.
You know?
I mean that's a metal fucking deck.
Crazy right now.
So many people have tattooed faces.
That's some serious
commitment tattoo on your mug.
Millions of dollars.
Yeah.
But I mean it might not work and you're
stuck with 69 I think tastes like an
asshole.
I think they probably might wait until
they get that first big check and they
may be getting in.
Did he wait?
I don't know about him particularly
if there's a controversy between uh,
is he a blood or is he a crip
and he's claiming he's both.
He does.
I'm friends with both of
them or something like that.
But he wears an awful lot of red
so people think that he's a blood.
What a weird weird were.
Cut that shit off.
Shot it off.
Stop.
We can't do this any more Jamie.
She makes me watch this car all the time.
Jamie's got his thumb on the pulse of
the Straits and he tells me my shit on
Instagram.
I find him fascinating.
Well there's a lot of
fascinating people today man.
That's Jamie also shows me
these girls with giant buts.
That's,
he knows all,
all know the real ones.
Real ones.
Real giant ass.
Cause they got the,
you can tell the not
because of the diaper,
but caper bud is a real
thing that looks real.
That's real as fuck,
dude.
Jesus Christ.
That makes me uncomfortable.
It's hot in here.
You know what's here?
See,
here's a fascinating thing to ask
was not a big deal for a long time.
For a long time,
he'd go back to like Linda
Carter and wonder woman.
You never saw her ass ever
asked was not a thing,
man ass Farrah Fawcett.
You never saw Farrah Fawcetts ass.
Right.
But now if a girl's
going to be a hot chick,
she's got to have a banging ass.
If a girl's like in a
movie as a hot chick,
there's going to be a point in the movie
where you see her in a pair of tight
jeans.
You Go,
whoa.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
That's an excellent set
that like when you did,
I like the,
I think he probably below big buts.
That's like all right here.
Yeah,
he's definitely dumped in.
There's definitely it up.
It's definitely a moment,
but always in the Mexican
community and the black community,
we were always into big butts.
We didn't need,
we didn't need society to tell us that.
We didn't know what the hell it was,
were just like big.
If scientific ground bots in the future
and they're studying the size of asses,
they'd be like,
well this is a noticeable jump in
women's asses at a certain point in time.
The 20th century.
Like what is that?
I saw this documentary once
called the history of sex.
It was on the science channel or something
was a five part documentary and they
were getting into why we,
we like certain things from the
opposite sex and the but apparently uh,
the reason,
well obviously like tits,
we like tits.
If they're big,
like we'd like them because we know
they're going to be able to feed the baby.
So we get a little endorphin rush big
because a woman can have birth give birth
easier.
So you,
you're attracted to that symmetry
according to this documentary,
the fat and the,
but it during the third
trimester of pregnancy,
that's when the brain develops.
And,
and,
uh,
the brain is developed from,
fat from the ass according
to this documentary.
So I guess we're looking at big round
asses for a smarter babies married.
That's what the documentary said.
I don't,
you know,
who knows.
Well,
they definitely know the shape of a woman
that's attractive to us because that's
the most fertile women,
the women that's going to be most likely
to hold a baby to term and raise the
child.
And that's why all those
qualities that you like.
And I'm like,
what a lot of men are really attracted
to nurturing women and he really
attracted to a woman who
wants to cook you dinner.
You know,
a woman who wants to
like give you a massage.
Like to a lot of guys,
that's a big deal because that's like a
nurturing type woman that would be not
just that way to you,
but that way to your children too.
We're talking about why scientifically
are men into big disease shapes or we're
also talking about how back in the day,
asses weren't a big deal
with Farrah Fawcett.
He never saw Farrah Fawcett task,
wonder woman.
Maryland
was curvy.
Nobody,
which wasn't sticking her ass out.
She was curvy though,
weren't you knew where it might've
happened in Wa [inaudible] Guerra girls
before they Amos,
but she was famous just for her ass.
Just stress with no Internet,
no Internet dude magazines.
Everybody knew who she was.
Rera mammas the all time ass queen.
Yo,
this was pre internet,
right?
Pre social media.
She was a bad son.
Get best but as fuck out of dodge
with that ass and that was end.
It was DNA and earned.
That wasn't,
he's a human or something chat.
Yeah,
that's exactly what she was.
[inaudible] guy fat and stuffing in it.
I dated her.
He was,
he was not into her.
He just likes dudes,
you know?
I don't know,
but he just,
he says just aim.
There was nothing to talk about with her.
Hey Man.
Sometimes I naturally talk with,
sometimes you just want to have
a conversation bro and snuggle.
She's a singer too.
Hey Dude.
Well sometimes just
want [inaudible] album.
She put out an album.
You know,
sometimes with a gal you
give her a book and you say,
Hey,
before we do anything physical,
you read this and I want to
read it and now let's talk.
Let's talk,
let's talk about the book.
To check out was a
great fucking reference.
Joe,
I forgot about Griffith.
She was my favorite.
I had a poster in my college,
dorm,
liver.
I would see what's impressive is
her ass superseded the Internet.
It like bypass.
It was before the end.
Thank was was there but it
wasn't why she got famous,
she got famous from magazines.
She was in low rider talk.
That low rider with that APP for sure.
She,
she had a push from the Internet.
There was dudes passing her picture around
and showed been way bigger if she was
current now what it,
yeah.
What I should say is,
well there's a lot of girls like her now.
She'd get lost in the shuffle.
What I'm saying is like then she was one
of the few girls that people would pass
or photos around pre social media.
Correct.
So wasn't like it was like this girl on
an Instagram page and she had 10 million
followers because of her ass.
It was like guys like you would go,
dude,
look at this and you would
send it to me and I'd go,
Jesus hung up posters and
people emailed each other.
The FHM maxim.
What year is this gender?
It doesn't say the bottom of the Barcode.
He's probably done 500 magazine,
2005 this is pre social media
dating Nicholas Shay or some shit.
My space,
my space time,
but that wasn't the same as like Twitter.
Facebook.
She had a tremendous my space.
Right?
Oh,
probably a hundred more questions.
Do you think she had Tom right
in the upper left hand corner?
What?
Tom?
Tom was always your first four
speed friend fucked up though.
He always had them in your fucking
top eight or whatever it was.
Yeah,
she is.
She still relevant on Instagram now?
She all old and weathered or she like,
well,
tome girl's name.
Who's the dime piece?
Who's on modern family.
Oh,
she's still killing it.
She's still looks good.
Congratulations.
I'm not mad at her.
At all.
Hey,
let's see if you find an actual,
there it is
still strong still.
Donut girl.
Strong,
strong gay.
Oh,
that,
that's some,
that's some DNA that's
from the motherland.
I Dunno where the motherland is,
but wherever it is that's
from the rover she's from.
That's another,
she tapped into that shit.
Like Maple Syrup,
God doggy.
Then she dates someone really famous.
I hope so.
I hope you found the show shows.
Congratulations doin good for it.
You still doing it was in this with her.
I'm getting hot.
You were saying it was hot earlier,
right?
I'll fill in all weird fellows.
Funky.
Sorry Dude.
So we got through this.
She's gonna have a million
followers after this podcast.
People though she is,
oh,
this was our first fight companion.
Uh,
other than kickboxing outside the UFC.
That's right,
man.
It's good.
It's been fun.
I'm sorry about the nuclear
bombs.
Good.
I was just getting to
the point you're making.
I get you just get a little caught up.
Doesn't spirits.
He's in.
Sometimes it's just,
I think dinosaurs are real,
bro.
That's all I'm saying.
I did something.
So I'm in Minnesota this weekend,
Friday,
Saturday,
Minnesota.
House of Commons Mall America.
Beautiful.
And now I'm in West Nyack.
The following note,
that Trivia,
that's where ours should fear.
Got arrested or was
almost getting arrested.
Drop it off edibles,
wasn't it?
Yeah.
So the less gay.com me and Sam Tripoli,
tinfoil hat,
comedy in San Francisco,
cops.
Oh Shit.
Friday,
June 1st and then at the
punchline in Sacramento.
Saturday,
June 2nd.
Get your tickets@livenation.com you've
been to me with me at that place.
Like a dumb fucking,
that's a big,
that's a great room.
Cops.
It's beautiful.
I love coffee.
And the next show at the comedy store,
I don't know if it's sold out.
We were doing those Joe
Rogan and friends' shows.
The next one is the 24th
of May 24th I don't know.
More with photos.
May 24th Joe rogan.com a young Jamie.
Get one of them.
Powerful tee shirts.
There's only a few left.
You fucks young.
Jamie has powerful hoodies
and all kinds of shit.
Young jamie.com bye.
See Ya.
That's a beautiful way to [inaudible].